do
hello we are here against all the odds
uh the meeting of Mines I won't say
great because what's a great mind anyway
fair but my and I say that for myself
but friendly Minds today
Beautiful Minds
Jeff wittick thank you for having me my
man
Mike Malik okay Malik well that sounds
like an eyeless yeah you didn't
Slaughter the J and said yeah but I yeah
I practice I practiced that so that's
pretty good for me people that know me
that's good and of course Tana Mojo
and did I say your last name right you
did okay you did because I practiced
that one too did you and I've talked
about you a lot and I was never really
clear on how to say it yeah I mean
that's fair I don't think you Ricky
names these two yeah yeah I know what
dude I can't believe we're sitting here
right now I know this is crazy it's
crazy I feel like I'm surrounded by
adverse adverse or adverse adversary you
got it I mean I mean dude listen at the
end of the day We're In Your Den you
know what I'm saying we're in the we're
in the Sharks you have a Nassau no NASA
control center like that runs I couldn't
believe how many people you had behind
the scenes and it shows in the products
yeah but I I'm you know he says I'm old
that's nice though that's respect yeah
we thought we were gonna get whacked
walking in here sketchy looking
Warehouse outside but very nice inside
yeah good to see all you guys it's crazy
because we're such we've been such a big
part of the show but we've never met I
know it's a good Enterprise way of
putting it first saw
you specifically because we talked in
text and stuff it was just kind of weird
that we had never met before but here we
are you know talked about all you guys
quite a bit
and so to sit here together you know I'm
in a this is a peace time for me oh by
the way shout out to our sponsor Harry's
Razors
good people over there getting carried
away this is a time of Peace for me this
is a time of uh
mature maturing I've got kids now okay
yeah why why is it why do you feel like
because of the kids no because I don't
know I just you know sometimes
I think what happened was during the
Frenemies era and I'm not going to blame
Trisha for me being an [ __ ] okay
but and we we kind of we kind of brought
it out in each other okay so I'm not I'm
not at all blaming her but I just you
know a lot happened a lot got caught up
and I just was hating on everyone I said
I'm a Prof I'm a hater ass [ __ ] I came
out of the closet last week as a hater
I've been there I've been there you know
it's like uh Alcoholics Anonymous for
hater so I'm coming out of the closet a
lot of good things came out of that era
believe it or not yeah I actually I
wouldn't change a thing wow thanks bro
it was a real eye-opening experience for
me
nice you don't have that you don't have
that Rim shot do you on your show we do
you do yeah I think it's overused I like
[ __ ]
well maybe we could hear the sound bites
they have a one guy specifically Zach
right specifically for sounds that's all
I knew that I was in the presence of a
great program yeah yeah because normally
the sound guy does a number of jobs
maybe they're like taking notes on stuff
that should be clipped or they're
sending something to the to you know to
the host of the show but just
specifically for sound like my favorite
one is I just [ __ ] my shorts you know or
like that that one about me [ __ ] in my
gym shorts yeah he should be able to
pull that you have that one yeah I [ __ ]
in my pants today yeah that one yeah but
that's see I come from the Howard Stern
era and Fred Norris just sound bites and
it adds so much texture to the show so
my dream was to have someone like Zach
we've been working together for a long
time and yeah that's basically his
specific job okay [ __ ] my pants okay
Ethan yeah okay Ethan that's a very I
hear that one my fave
okay Ethan and that was a problem it was
almost perfect that was lined up what is
that from our first oh when I came on
the show live thank you for not doing
this live yeah of course absolutely how
was that I don't think I ever watched
that it was bad it was watching it was
rough yeah it was one of the worst
things I was sitting there
why'd you do it because listen
that's not the only person who's decided
they wanted to live take on Ethan and
the Army what are the foot soldiers
right yeah we had Wiki feet we had the
fall of Jeff whittick we had the fall of
not the well okay the temp there was a
wake-up call let's call it a wake-up
call but at the time it was a fall I
felt it was a fall but yeah go on well
just my little brother Aidan Ross
decided he wanted to give it a shot yeah
that was nice to see him come down with
me though
I kind of felt like all right It's just
tough man here's one of the things about
this show versus other shows or other
people you guys prepare you're very well
prepared you're a bit you're a bit older
a bit more mature yeah you have a
cultural and traditional you know stance
on things and so when a 25 or 23 or 28
year old call or even a uh you know
four-year-old in the case of crowder
who's a [ __ ] ass loser yeah saw that
with Sam Cedar yeah that was a surprise
that was like a Cody code Jake Paul
moment for a second right out of nowhere
dude like that was one of my favorite
moments with your show right
you know what is this thing uh convince
me otherwise or something yeah yeah
debate me to change my mind my mind I
think you changed it for a second that
day it seemed like
a setup situation you're an ambush he is
so Crowder wanted he's you know who
Stephen Crowder is yeah yeah so he
wanted to debate me on something I don't
remember what it was and we're like dude
this guy's such a [ __ ] loser like I'm
not gonna debate him on some deep
political [ __ ] and so there's this guy
Sam Cedar who
is like his rival and he's always been
dodging him in a debate uh and so we
figured out this way to we got on the
zoom call live or no it was pre-recorded
that's your YouTube boxing right there
yeah yeah yeah the pen with the brain we
managed to to get him into the zoom call
covertly
and it was just it was good fireworks
but speaking of uh preparation we are
prepared I agree because today is the
bfffff show I love it I love it there's
been an ongoing competition to who's
going to be my bestie you know I've been
teetering between you guys
but uh after today you might be in the
room oh my god
um I'll try my best okay I've been dying
to be so the first thing I want to do is
bring out the hats uh sorry you don't
have to wear because you have beautiful
hair but I appreciate it but I'm about
to but you can you're encouraged dude
so here we have the hats okay now you
guys have heard of the BFF podcast well
that's over that's over this is the
bffff podcast so are you Fortnight in
this
look at me all right so who's Josh
Richards is that me would that be oh
yeah I guess this is a new show there's
no archetypes oh got it got it you know
okay forget about BFF okay that's just
dead to me yeah
I'm only friends with the people in this
room everyone else get [ __ ] who would
have thought that would hey that hey by
the way the H3 Dave pornoy podcast is a
great podcast you should listen they
invited me on don't just draw the line
with with the Olive Branch from us I
like all the way yeah yeah he invited me
on his podcast just like yesterday
listen Dave's on apologetic yeah that's
iconic he's very Unapologetic you know
what I'm saying he sticks to his guns
and I think there's I think there's some
uh there's something to be said about
that in today's current Society all
right well we got the hats
hold on to your thoughts there Mike
you're getting ahead you're getting too
excited okay all right so this so we
have a ceremony here okay and the French
in the spirit of friendship who would I
ever thought of this one is okay now
here uh guys go ahead open that open
this go ahead open that guys and then we
each have a friendship bracelet it's
just like Anthrax one's for you Jeff
yeah it's just a sniff anthrax
don't worry so everyone put on is this
for you guys yeah do we put on oh you
pass those three out
as a declaration of friendship of Anna
oh baby the
one do you ever done this at the end of
the show after we like what if you tell
me how to do my [ __ ] show give me the
bracelet dude all right now you take one
Jeff and Mike there you go
Mike did I give you the wrong one I got
tana and Mike yeah
listen if you don't want to be my bestie
I want to be arrested okay all right I
don't have it so when you say that yeah
when you say that you're looking for a
new BFF do you almost mean to fill the
internet's void of Frenemies or do you
no just like that's what I was worried
about this is what I was worried about
you two get together and then what about
me I'm just cut out it's been five
minutes no no one no one can replace you
that's not no it's just like you know
the the proverbial bestie
yeah we're besties you guys are cry you
guys are going crazy right now you're
awesome it's good yeah but also so now
we also have guys if you could all bring
out your friendship bracelets at this
moment because actually in the BFF
running everybody has a horse you all
have supporters in this office so if you
guys could pass out your bracelet I know
who it is my man a b the glasses look at
the glasses and the hat go ahead guys
yeah just pass out your friendship
bracelets thank you that's ab's
declarations yeah Olivia oh my God
thank you everybody
it's really good thank you one of you
smells really really you guys ever get
plural thank you
means a lot brother thank you plurp get
blur guys
thank you this looks like me on Molly at
a rave a long time ago wait what Jeff
doesn't oh maybe I got a couple yeah
okay you really didn't get that many
actually you know what's crazy is that
damn you guys don't have as many
bracelets yeah you have the most
I would assume it's because you're
responsible for payroll
that's crazy that I have so many more
braces
more of everything than us more
employees More Money More sanity and I'm
sure more sanity maybe yeah maybe okay
and then guys if you could take off your
shirts please but not in like a weird
way they have Team affiliations
okay I don't saw FaZe Clan yeah see this
is why we're for fun today bro these
dude
Anna no no no no no no no no we're just
kind of crazy is there some sort of
printing error or something wait there's
four oh Zach All right so team Mike is
Zach
this is all real affiliations guys this
is all how it came down I mean AB just
told me on the side he said this is all
pre-decided by Ethan no you did it no
you didn't you wouldn't say that it's
just he wouldn't go against the family
there's just one a three team Jeff wow
so you so you've got quite a lot of
supporters there a b Lena and cam wait
ab's team Tana yeah oh what once oh your
team yeah you guys had you and your wife
end up on different teams it's kind of
odd what is Dan huh what is that you and
Lena end up on different teams I
couldn't decide between Justin Mike team
Banks there's a team yeah yeah
thanks he got the Boston hat on that
sleeved tattoo and everything all right
so then we got we got Jeff who's team
Mike one person right here dude just
Zach oh and Ian too and Ian's team Mike
yeah with the gym oh where just what
we have uh
where we got here we've got Olivia how
do you know now uh probably disappointed
no the girls are are riding for you and
of course Dan was a holdout
what's the deal we were having a
conversation the other day and we kind
of floated Banks as being another BFF
possibility but you kind of iced them
out and I didn't really like how you did
my boy dirty like that so what do you
talk do you talk to Banks ever I've
talked to him I know that yeah you guys
have talked on Twitter and stuff yeah
yeah yeah
that's funny Dan is it uh he's on team
nobody here yeah you're right what a
surprise too yeah I got a bone to pick
with Dan but I'll wait for them to give
me the Godfather soundtrack all right
okay all right yeah so so basically now
that we're all plured out you know it's
all about love and affection everyone I
mean I have quite a lot more than like
specifically you only yeah I think a
foal is kind of sad but it's okay
because he made the rules
right real good energy in this place
right so but now let's we're moving on
okay so let's move on guys so first of
all let's just say hi
um
thank you guys all for being here I feel
like we already did the intro
um Tana you came and you know a lot of
people were afraid you were gonna flake
I had faith in you the whole time did
you yeah I thought for sure I love this
newfound faith in me I don't know where
it came from I must be on a on a peace
Roll No I said listen she's showing up
no I'm not dead and stupid I would have
been ripped to shreds had I not shown up
let's be real and I just could not give
you that I got surgery yesterday and I
woke up this morning gushing blood and I
was like well I'm gonna gush blood at H3
before I [ __ ] lose all my does it
hurt to talk yeah yeah she was wanting
to go through for more reasons than one
really yeah what's the other one I'm
scared of anything I'm gonna [ __ ] say
it's uh gonna get me canceled by the
what do you call the foot what soldiers
that's you guys it's just because we
[ __ ] up Wiki food it's not like a real
army how'd you [ __ ] up wikiFeet well I
got permanently banned from wikiFeet in
fact we ruined the whole wikiFeet men's
side it's a long story her damn I was
number one on the website and people
weren't happy wait actually so what is
that that's like a Wikipedia for
people's feet right you don't know about
wikiFeet you don't know you're
definitely I've heard about it I'm a big
fan of the show Believe it or not I've
been watching for a long time are you
serious yeah I know what you're doing I
I've been watching since Vape Vape
Nation Way Back big H3 fan over here he
so he's a fan of the audience too thank
you no no and I know
try it buddy but look Mike give him a
Mike give me a chance to talk look I
went through a lot of the past couple
years right I had to do a lot of things
that I didn't think I I could even
possibly do I didn't think I had the
strength or courage to do it and I went
toe-to-toe with one of the biggest dogs
on the platform here and I knew that
there was a lot of people that were
going to turn on me no matter what and
this audience here
supported me they made me believe in
myself and I just want to thank you and
the audience here and the team the whole
H3 team are you serious but specifically
the audience yeah they backed me up on a
lot of stuff whoa
well I personally I like I think our
fans are great too but but I'm happy to
hear that yeah yes maybe you know look
at him rolling his eyes go I'd say it
too Mike you want to hop in this
piggyback on this one I'm not gonna say
that dude I mean the audience has been
great to me lately because I think they
know me and you were a little yeah I
mean let's be honest I don't want to say
this I wasn't going to [ __ ] do most
in the polls well well I have the I have
the updates because the first poll uh
the best friend pull we did a poll of
the our live audience for for who's my
new bestie uh buy by vote here I've got
the stats the first vote was a uh
resounding resounding win
we don't have to stop that's what I
wanted to get I don't want to brag about
this you know it's just he started Maybe
uh the first poll I believe it was 80
20. 83. well hold on so so there's
nothing no no stop stop before you go
yeah it's not a big deal there was some
there was some fooling around going on
on both poles I want to say on the first
poll specifically FaZe Banks was
randomly involved at the last moment is
there it's gonna stop and I believe that
he took a small portion of my voter base
you know me and Banks share more of a
voter base than Jeff and Banks oh yeah
so you simply split the votes on the
first one and it showed in the second
one which was the second poll it was
just Jeff and Mike narrow quite a bit
Mike actually showed up strong 48 well
that's 52 that is the one because you
had this whole narrative that I don't
like women driving
no no this was out of context I have a
1980 Silverado it's 42 years old it
would have been anybody I would have had
to walk them down there start the car
for them and you guys just clipped out
this one part and of course they were
having a good laugh saying oh Jeff
doesn't
but there was also a large amount of I
think we call it gerrymandering after
the fact as well what did we call it
political talking news there was a whole
there was a whole bunch of phone around
on that one too and the vote was set it
was it was in favor of me yeah and Truth
Mike was winning and then I corrected
the record I said this is out of context
you know I don't think Jeff would would
as a true BFF yeah and so then the poll
came back up and just to be fair but
that that's basically where we're at
yeah also Jeff whittick on wikiFeet just
to see you guys up here actually I'm
trying to say how am I doing over there
well you're doing
um wow they're updated it's pretty good
yeah you have some good foot shots yeah
I have ugly feet man you have a 4.1
but to be honest you might have a lot of
one stars from our full War Days oh yeah
hey I deserve it I mean I run too much
myself
oh god oh wow Logan got absolutely
bodied uh no that's no this is Mike yeah
0.4 I don't even have a page so my you
know my feet are terrible I have flat
feet but I'm just gonna give you five
and then pull up ten pretend you
probably have a great score I don't know
because sometimes my feeder I let them
look cute and sometimes it's supposed
the guys the the wiki feet watch them
have a better rating than me no it's
very true you have a perfect score yeah
that was from yesterday down no dude
down there when we do a live show with
someone flashes foot it's up there
immediately like no people are so
dedicated zoom in on the Stars let me
just see if there's a sliver missing
yeah look there's a shot of me fighting
I don't even remember that yo this
appears to be that is a perfect perfect
score how do they know my shoe size did
they get it right yeah these people are
[ __ ] animals dude it's crazy you have
a lot of votes too Tana wait where do
you 657. I see see that's nice and all
but I have my own Instagram page for my
feet called Hey Big Mike's Feed yeah
I know deep down you're running that no
I'm not I swear to God oh deep down
you're running there I want to do that
honestly me but you know what I want to
say is like foot soldiers out there I
you know I'm not on Wiki feet but for my
besties you might want to go in there
and share your opinion on their feet and
you know foreign
I've been banned I'm permanently banned
my numbers on that website I had like 20
000 one star reviews nobody could hold a
candle to me in fact there was even
certain points
Mike Hey Big Mike's feet yeah yeah look
at those flippers man that's a real shot
of your foot bro
yeah yeah I have a medical condition
I've planted Planters fasciitis is that
can somebody that's like a straight
that's just like an L I know it's a big
L dude it's hard to walk on wait can you
make it bigger
it's horrific dude medical conditions
medical condition you might make fun of
that oh no I would never all right yes I
just want to get things going yeah you
know so anyway it looks like your foot
Got Run Over By like a cartoon car or
some [ __ ] yeah just
just like toothpaste out of the side all
right let's let's get to the the beef
basically we've got a lot going on
between us a lot of history lots of ends
lots of outs first of all Mike's or Jeff
my best friend Jeff seems uh to be
chomping at the bit to say something to
Dan you guys have a historic conflict
you got you want you have something you
want to tell Dan no I was just goofing
around I don't care look I'm here to
make peace as well today speak your
heart though
um no I don't care about the eye jokes
um I like to lean into those myself so
kind of like the crane
those jokes are fine with me you know it
is what it is
um I don't want to get I don't want to
be the guy to start this haul you know
Dan do you want to start it off maybe
you gotta go in well I don't know speak
from your heart guys we're never gonna
resolve anything unless we're open and
honest I'm gonna be open and honest
right now I I you I don't know
specifically what it is that you're
upset about Jeff but I do feel like
right off the bat we got off on the
wrong foot because when you came on
Frenemies that time on that Infamous
episode I I believe you confused me with
another crew member because the first
thing that you said was
something about my Tick Tock account in
kind of a sarcastic way I'm not on Tick
Tock so I remember that you're you're
maybe with like misdirected at the wrong
crew members it was maybe it was me yeah
I would never say that about a b oh man
yeah
so wait you I we have a recalling that
AB says at one point you wanted to fight
AV well this is this is what Dan is
talking about whenever he first called
in he said there's some room in that
Tick Tock for his YouTubers boxing match
AB if you want to get in there but yeah
he thought I was Dan right so so I feel
like that that's right off the bat we
were there was some confusion there
about who was who and everything so
maybe today is the day to just hit the
reset you are wearing a bank shirt
though oh I thought you're gonna say
maybe today's the day to get in the ring
I like the recent button let's do that
you like that better because we do have
a ring set up downstairs yeah I mean I'm
down I am down to no no
I wanted to go to this stuff a little
later let's talk
um I was hoping we could maybe touch on
tanacon and let me do a deep dive in the
NFP and then we'll get this stuff later
on I'm sure we're going oh man all right
so how long is this [ __ ] body uh
we're just getting started
prisoners is basically just the tips try
to leave the doors as blocked yeah it's
blocked from the outside we were talking
about having to walk off on the way oh
it might still have it who knows all
right let's throw it to a quick break
we've got one ad we'll we'll thank them
and we'll be right back thank you to
Harry's Razors back to school wedding
season holiday prep we're all cutting it
close this season as we go straight from
one thing to another and with incredibly
sharp razors that refill
just in the nick of time Harry's is the
official sponsor of cutting it close I
love Harry's man besides it being a
great deal these razors cut
I'll tell you what I've had one in my
shower
for months
and it still works good you I swear to
God I just I don't use it Vermont I just
shaved the back of my head because I'm a
hairy freak right back here
for months this thing stays uh it stays
sharp it's got this beautiful weighty
handle I mean it's really the best deal
it's the best deal in the game for women
too Eli uses it on her leg
foreign
good for everything
not just for guys
hey check this out right now you can get
Harry's starter set for just three bucks
plus you'll get a free travel size body
wash that includes a five blade razor
weighted handle foaming shave gel and a
travel cover that's a 16 value just for
three bucks
for three bucks you can see what I'm
talking about at harrys.com slash
H3 that's harrys.com
no matter how busy things get stay fresh
with Harry's get your hairy starter set
today and you'll also get a free travel
sized body wash
just go to harrys.com H3 that's
harrys.com you guys are gonna love this
blade thank you to our sponsors and
thank you to everybody who supports our
sponsors thank you thank you with peace
and love
well I want to do a segment here guys
where we squash the beef literally and
symbolically we have here today A giant
Vice
and also big slabs of meat that I want
to squash with you guys okay yeah bring
it out please bring out the the vice
vice yeah yeah and so I want to go over
some of our historic beefs that we had
together have you and I ever beefed
like I know it's just kind of you like
this that's exactly beating me that's
exactly what it has been yeah yeah no
you've never I don't think you've ever
said a bad thing about me Dan just
bashes my skull in with this from behind
yeah you remember Goodfellas a [ __ ]
heading to Vice Charlie M oh yeah did
you want to do something with the uh
Casino you got the you made me pop your
[ __ ] I already had for Charlie M
Charlie I'm that piece of [ __ ] we're
here with an olive branch
we've had too many problems in the past
the North and South has been divided
we've had all kinds of problems but
today
we put those problems in a vice
once and for all oh gloves okay oh
interesting that was a really good
Godfather impression how do you feel
about that Ethan well yeah not good
honestly I don't like it don't maybe
don't do that again all right keep a lid
on that okay and maybe maybe turn off
your mic dude
you don't need to we don't need you
adding any commentary thank you so
um
so here we have big slabs of meat okay
do you guys get [ __ ] from the vegan
Community when you do stuff like this I
think because because you guys stress
out about the communities don't you like
the individual communities yeah we can't
partake in this one no I can't I don't
give a hot water dude but like I'm just
saying like do you I I I I like do you
think like Veggie Grill is gonna drop
you as a sponsor I don't have any I
don't have many sponsors left out
um
so
I I suspect some people get mad about
this but you know I eat meat
like liver king would you ever would you
ever what if we use the meat that you
put in this and we symbolically eat we
can eat it I think that would because I
would eat it I think that's gonna piss
off the communities if you waste it
that's what I'm saying or let's just at
least say we're gonna eat it okay you
know what I mean Montreal so we'll put
some Montreal steak on it have you
cleaned the vice no
oh yeah probably not good there's
probably metal sharks in there for sure
dude I've ingested my Sheriff toxins
yeah um
what's your craziest uh drug story Mike
while we set this up there's just so
many man like Stevo told us one where he
snorted blood I mean mine's really
mine's I have a really sad like rock
bottom but it's just really sad yeah
like I don't want to bum out your
audience no I don't want to hear that
one it involved like my dying
grandfather and I was like smoking crack
yeah you were smoking crap when your
grandpa was on like his deathbed next to
him same room no oh no that's horrifying
like it's just like okay okay yeah this
just is pretty down Tempo stuff it's
like my rock bottom we talk about it as
like a mo that was the moment where I
realized I had to get my life together
you know what I'm saying all right
oh cool sorry that happened you want me
to find a better you want me to find a
better one like about an accident like a
festival or something like well hold on
to that thought save it for your second
book or something
all right here we go we're all queued up
here so
what beef is this this is a uh looks
like a nice cut yeah honestly yeah oh no
I was saying what specific so let's
we're gonna start with I guess uh here
Tana okay so I'm gonna take these this
is pretty gross sorry
quite disgusting
um I love it so Tana I'm gonna start
with you ours is pretty light like you
noted and I'll just you just called me
like a super spreading face tuning like
idiotic hooker I never called you a
hooker let's back it up now I think
you're right A lot of it has been uh me
just uh insulting you and I don't think
you've ever said a bad thing about me
and so yeah I'm a hater ass [ __ ]
honestly it feels great to hear but I
will say that definitely done my fair
share of dumb things so I'm no stranger
to people uh
commentating on that you know you were
pretty wild during back in the day
during like you know the idubbz thing or
whatever but it seems like these days
you're really
for the past several years
you kind of just uh doing your own thing
in a good way you're not really ruffling
any feathers or maybe I'm not paying
attention enough I like to ruffle the
smaller feathers now you know low
hanging fruit if you will I try to I try
to um
stay out of things you know but I'm here
today to
her like core activity zone is only fans
yeah which and that's my core of
activity I mean that's where you do the
majority of your like lifting right and
it's like so like there's not really
financially fine I mean do do you
produce a lot of content for other
channels besides of I guess Tick Tock
YouTube My podcast yeah that makes sense
okay no no I'm actually Justin only
Fan's [ __ ] yeah but but that's the
majority of your income right at this
point that's where I was going down
thank you yeah so it's your focus it's
not the I mean it's one of my main
sources
I just meant like they're not like it
was just what is it you're trying to say
exactly what I was getting at was like
there's no way to really be problematic
on all in your mind yeah you know what
I'm do you get what I'm well that's not
actually true because uh I've seen some
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah for sure but it has it
has it like induced like a sponsor
pulling [ __ ] well you're already on
the only fans what are they gonna do I
mean your sponsor's already been pulled
I think there's some people that do you
you do both you do both yeah you do
sponsors you could do like a I'm not
gonna say a comp a company right now
because they're not paying but like you
could do sponsorships and only fans just
no no I was saying it's when the people
are paying you they're they're the ones
in charge and uh They're Not Gonna Leave
You you can get sponsors and do all my
fans yeah yeah yeah it's not like you're
doing anything so let's so so I think
the the big one that comes to mind uh
with us Tana is when I called you a
Twinkie okay oh oh I forgot about that
and a lot of people bring that up and
actually Trisha would bring that up
quite a bit to me uh and so what I
wanted to do is basically just suppose
can we not what is this this is yeah oh
you were you were coming at my neck
there was an old photo of me looking
really
awful and then the face tune and then I
guess people were saying you were fat
shaming me
let's take a look at it and then we can
destruct it and deconstruct the reason
you started at that exact frame or you
know yeah you know this link was handed
to me got it
so whatever's on the TV at this moment
is out of my control I was actually
thinking about if you were gonna bring
this up or not on here
and then um I was like I'll just get
naked on three and prove it now oh
you're willing to do that first okay
good yeah so I have no control over
what's on the TV guys what's going on
here yeah got me involved in new stuff I
think it's a photo of me looking in an
olive branch not a not looking for World
War III all right no no let's move it on
oh damn oh this one's so bad smart Mike
oh peace sorry
I'm sorry
yeah look at that she's fit then admit
she's beautiful iconic that was a bad
thing you know the video was um
Instagram versus reality and I was just
going over all the top posts from that
fair I think that day I mean I don't
know it's not a good one
moment I did call you a Twinkie hey just
it was really just the color of this one
yeah I think I needed to hit the gym and
I think that I had a body is beautiful
and perfect the way it was then and now
just throwing this out there do you know
uh the one food that would survive a uh
nuclear Holocaust yeah a Twinkie correct
so like and by the way yes he was the
nuclear hole what does that say about it
there yeah it's just a powerful food man
it's a great snack it's definitely
giving bad angles a lot of face tuned
preservatives I don't know man since
then I've hit the gym a lot and I faced
June a lot less you wanna do you have a
daughter no I have two boys damn it yeah
I didn't have kittens then
but um sitting here across from you I do
want you to know that to be honest wrong
with this body you're beautiful well I
mean no at the time I definitely was not
a fan of even remote this was years ago
very old very very long time ago I don't
even think I'd reached like internet
real like clout yet and then that was
when people were kind of coming out and
then I definitely got a lot of
injections and went to the gym a lot but
how did that come how did that comment
make you feel Tana how did it make me I
mean it at the time I definitely didn't
like you and yeah coming from you and I
was kind of like yeah [ __ ] that yeah
right I mean I don't know but did it
hurt you did it like push you into like
a frenzy or anything I should say yes so
that it could like you'd look like pick
your mind
speak your mind I really think that you
I don't know you just weren't on my
radar at that point in time I was I was
more
scared or hurt by times when you would
kind of come for me for things I was
doing wrong I felt like this was like
the tanacon stuff on the podcast yeah I
guess so yeah when I came
listen I was ready to show up here in a
bikini today oh my God uh but uh did you
really think about doing that uh no I
was just thinking about things you'd
come
tune or listen this is this is I
wouldn't
I would never make fun of a woman's
appearance like this well you did I know
and I'm very sorry right I shouldn't
have done I I definitely think that
I can think about a lot of girls who
couldn't take it you know what I mean
like I've been called Everything Under
the Sun I've been made fun of for like
every
thing across my career but imagine like
that your thoughts are right on it but
it but like let's pull away from this
situation specifically for a second and
look at a more macro view of like
bullying on the internet in general like
like we've reached we've kind of reached
like a Apex and like a time of in an
inflection point with bullying on the
internet right now like people are are
people being [ __ ] yeah or people or
people that are saying people are
[ __ ] just overlooking the fact that
people are actually hurt by other
people's comments right and so I think
this is like a disco more macro
discussion right I lean more on the side
of uh
in general people are not just being
[ __ ] you know uh but but what I've
messed up here is the video was like
Instagram reality and a lot of people
appreciated it because it was like and
body acceptance but where I [ __ ] up is
I shouldn't have made fun of like I kind
of lost my lost my what did Trisha say
like what was Trisha saying at the time
just whenever she wanted to uh use
something against me or prove that I
hate whim or something she would just
saying
yeah I mean honestly I think you
motivated me even I think at the time
that you called me and I was at a good
body but I you know I'm very sorry I
should not make the point I think what I
was trying to make it was valid because
that's why I didn't feel bad but going
after your body was was too far
even though it pushed you to be better
well I think but by the time he had
called me this I was out like like I
looked great I was happy with my body
but I mean like you know now I can see
myself being on the treadmill and
thinking like [ __ ] I don't want to be I
want to be a Twinkie I mean it is funny
that's the thing the twinkie thing was
kind of like well not like a whole no
one or like another oh like a different
Hostess Street you know you
do you remember yodels though uh can you
guys pull up yodels I don't I think
they're one of the better ones what else
have you come at my neck anyway
apologies for that you know I think
you're saying yeah I know I shouldn't
have said that I don't want to comment
on this one anybody
um I do feel bad about making fun of
your weight but do you ever think that
people maybe do things like that because
of comments that you made like that the
people that there are insecure girls out
there that do try to uphold a certain
image because of comments like that yeah
yeah that's why I think it was a bad it
was bad and I don't really make I
wouldn't really do that today make that
comment I don't think yeah
interesting yeah let's learn you live
and you learn I forgot about that yeah
yeah I don't think at the time it I just
always knew you like hated me so I think
that was just one of the like million
comments that you'd probably you know
that's one of the things that I regret
too is I don't really hate I of course I
don't hate you at all you know I love
how we're just discussing this with like
this nasty ass yeah well it's important
to keep in the context while we're here
yeah um you know I I never hated you at
all and and uh
what do you think made you like that in
that era of time and I mean obviously
there was a lot of it that was very
valid you know you were coming at people
for doing a lot of wrong and stuff and
that was good you know like to have
someone on the internet who's polarizing
kind of calling people out for being
shitty people but a lot of the like
hating just straight up hating comments
towards people like what do you think
made you like that
well I don't think I did much like
random hating I think I took it too far
into terms of like talking about your
body I took it too far no I don't just
mean me but I'm saying I think at the
time you know
I honestly don't know I mean from my
whole time on
YouTube
was uh calling people out for one reason
or another and it became like a whole
industry of videos on on YouTube where
it's like and even today still exists of
like call out videos or reaction videos
or whatever and
um
you know I think it was just part of the
trend at the time to do that
but looking back obviously as I've spent
more time on the internet and matured
and have like I think now uh more I
would say just woke quote unquote
audience and I myself and more woke just
to use kind of an annoying word uh that
that uh I'm I'm a lot more careful with
the what I say about people
but one of the differentiators with U2
that you know kind of separates you from
other people in that space that do
commentary and do reaction videos is you
wield a massive [ __ ] Army bro and so
like what's that saying with great power
comes great responsibility right
Spiderman you know what I'm saying like
do you ever do you feel like you need to
be a little bit more cautious about what
you say because because one thing that
that
I'm very cautious of and I'm sure we'll
talk about it in some respect that my
good friend Logan Paul has taught me is
to be very careful in when you speak in
absolutes when you say very specific
absolute statements that leave no room
for wiggle basically like the personal
like uh nope was the worst movie I've
ever seen that was a take but listen but
in in his it's
he he had created this list this hit
list of reasons
and listen at the end of the day like
you have subjective opinions right but
like
do do you feel like you have to be a
little bit more cautious than the
average uh I I know this probably won't
maybe you guys don't believe it but I
feel like my whole career I have been
more restrained and careful than other
people and only gone after people that I
think deserved it now like I don't know
if you can give me a specific example of
stuff that you guys think maybe I went
too far on and then I can reflect on it
are we just gonna get there anyways I
feel like you're probably gonna get us
there anyways right yeah I mean Now's
the Time Dive Right into my situation
yeah with you yeah
um
at the time was rough yeah I hated you
but
did I go I mean we we you obviously had
like a rough interview right yeah and
there was a reason I was pressing there
it was kind of like an issue that we
needed to get to the heart of
but I think with you I've been you know
I've I
have a lot of empathy for you I liked
you as a person that's why we're here
today yeah and so yeah I under I can
understand from your perspective it was
probably a painful and difficult to deal
with like the receiving ended that much
well I willingly came on the show
because I felt I had nothing to hide I'm
not ashamed of anything yeah and I said
what's the Worst That Could Happen was I
in the right State of Mind at the time
no yeah you know it was in and out of
surgery on meds
and it's you're asking me about a
situation three years ago now five I
don't remember what I said about Dan or
a B on you know it
so yeah I wasn't prepared for that type
of thing and I felt like I was the kid
in making a murderer you know right you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah and I try
to talk to you about it afterwards and
there was no door for us to even have
that conversation yeah well
at that point I wasn't really sure what
I don't think it was unfair though
necessarily because on one hand I
appreciated that you were willing to
like come on the show and put yourself
out there I mean no one else would do
that and so I believe that you earnestly
uh
at this point I showed me a picture that
I was at a party yeah and that was the
hard-hitting okay Ethan yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah judge [ __ ] you know so yeah
I was I was hurt at that time
um
but at the end of the day you know you
you were going after something bigger
and I was dealing with something that I
hadn't even I was covering up you know I
hadn't said anything to anybody right
second Trisha started going talking
about that I had just got so nervous
that that was going to come out because
that's my whole life it's the most
embarrassing moment of my life and now I
was gonna let the internet control the
narrative I wasn't gonna have a say in
my story so that's why I was we never
brought it up though before you did we
she did on the show yeah she did bring
it up the first time I ever heard about
it was from her
and uh it kind of blew my mind when I
found out about like the whole David and
the excavator thing yeah but at the end
of the day I'm happy that came out
because if I bottled that up inside
forever I'd be living in hell so thanks
to Trisha maybe thank you for my
situation I don't regret anything you
know yeah but for somebody I don't think
we're ready to squash tennis beef yet I
think but you do forgive me for the
twinkie comment
um I I don't I mean forgive sure I don't
I people do that does it make me look at
you as a different kind of person maybe
a little bit yeah okay you know a little
resolution but I'm but I'm sure that you
look at me as a bad person no I don't I
swear I don't so um
that's what I that's what annoys me
about my whole shtick is that like we
did the same thing happened with Ninja
and that's what started the whole
Redemption uh uh hater ass [ __ ] uh uh
metamorphosis there was that clip of
ninja being like I know Ethan hates me
and I was like man this [ __ ] sucks
dude because I don't hate him at all I
like Ninja
today to talk about I'm just saying that
I had in our friendship and squash yeah
no I'm just saying that that I do I have
that effect where people think I hate
them and well I mean it's easy it would
be easy to mistake that I mean you you
have some some really
rough takes on a lot of stuff and a lot
of stuff that you say is is dividing and
polarizing and hurtful yes but but the
the issue that I've had and the reason I
try to be cautious when I talk about
other people on the Internet is because
at the end of the day you don't know any
of us in any meaningful way you could
watch every clip Under the Sun you could
hear about every excavator tanacon
crypto scam Under the Sun yeah no well
no I'm just dropping and at the end of
the day until you meet us and you have a
conversation with us you understand our
vulnerable
vulnerabilities are our pain points our
anxieties our depressions our stressors
our we're normal people just like you
are you have your problems and that's
why I couldn't I could never it's harder
for me and I've definitely had my share
of stuff to say and I'm sure we'll get
into it but it's why it's I try now to
be very cautious about how I talk about
other people because I don't know
exactly what the [ __ ] is going on in
their life yeah you know what I'm saying
but but there needs to be room for
criticizing people's actions without but
that I think that's the problem my
disconnect is like I criticize people
actions I don't hate actually don't hate
them at all I think it starts to blend
in transition I think you're completely
right by saying yo I have a proven
reason why this person did something and
that and that thing was wrong and that
deserves my like but for the record Tana
did nothing wrong I made rude comments
you did nothing too so that's it so am I
the only person you've ever done that to
or do you think you had an era where you
could be honest I don't think there's a
lot of people I made fun of for without
any provocation damn so I was just like
you may have been just been look at you
fell into this video right this
Instagram I've seen it I understand in
my mind I Justified it because I was
like well what she's doing is like
negatively affecting women and Beauty
stanzas and stuff and so I you I get
this like enemy mentality where it's
like they're the end there it is they're
in the golf and I can [ __ ] say
whatever I want about them within reason
right yeah I mean I could have been
worse than that I'm I'm sure you have
been yeah but but you know what I I
don't know do you guys think if I I want
hello
yeah
speak up if you know the show half the
show is us arguing with Ethan yeah be
honest yeah even though he pays us he is
open to criticism he's open to push back
which is awesome it's really awesome I
will say oh yeah we brought all this
meat out we need you to be sorry we
haven't squashed a damn thing
there's not even one crank on that [ __ ]
I just hope you know that I'm not here
seeking any sort of apology for anything
that you've said I'm indifferent I'm
just I'm here for the Vibes you know
yeah Vibes only
all right speaking for ourselves it is a
rare case because we are social media
people we don't give a [ __ ] we're
desensitized to a lot of this stuff
especially Tana speaking for Tana not
all women just you you have uh you know
you joke around a lot about yourself
you're very deprecating so it's hard to
compare you to other people but we're
here today to squash our beats yeah you
know we're not trying to change the
world yeah 100 yeah
so have a conversation I just like
having a conversation too yeah so do you
guys I just want to see this yeah we're
getting there we're getting there we're
getting there but my my honestly mine
feels light too dude like I feel like
there's not really that you actually
have a fat you have the fattest chunk of
it yeah yeah you got a big old stuff oh
damn I walked into an ambush my bad Mike
no it's not an ambush we're squashing
but anyway I'm sorry do you mind
cranking that if if it's in your heart
to squash our beef is squashed I don't
really care to touch that you wanna you
wanna put I have a glove do you want to
put on the glove to do it yeah it's
important you do it yeah oh you have a
fat uh Nails on maybe Tana you are Tana
you Tana you want me to handle this you
give me the okay yeah yeah kind of give
me the okay to handle her body Jeff do
it for me no no Tana Tana you have to
you have to you really do have to why
did I sign up for today lift it up and
then just Twisted that way okay
and there you go could you maybe lift it
forward to and just
yeah yay
I mean you want me to handle the rest of
this here
a little revolution of it
but also Jeff one revolution that's what
our
yeah there you go there you go that's
enough
well we're getting there you want to
just blow that one up
okay go ahead you can smash it Jeff come
on we gotta I gotta watch this thing 15
[ __ ] times hey Peter Peter Jeff did
this not me
this is all Jeff
hey do you want your notes in that GoPro
video
just curious you can see the dock well
that's I don't know if you care this is
like the kind of stuff oh yeah no no I
don't want it in there so turn your
computer a little bit yeah that's
actually Dan will tell me that all right
so let's take a look here done deal
done deal
so there you go uh uh let's see let's
take a look oh it's disgusting dude
was kind of the idea but so okay the
other thing was you know on Frenemies we
we had talked about you a couple times I
mean and uh again no yeah yeah we're
still on you thank God right yeah yo
these were some wild evenings this was
the crazy yeah this [ __ ] was pretty nice
did you shave your brows off yeah I was
here wow that's dope I did some kind of
costume where I shaved it all off oh I
talked about this with Trisha a little
bit on
yeah but her standpoint is kind of that
you you were the coercer no into these
conversations and me I don't know that
I'm just relaying well let's just watch
I I saw she did something people were
calling out for photoshopping over the
weekend and you know what can I just say
as much as I was like against your video
I mean she really does overdo it because
I did see the side by side from this
weekend
because she had to come up with a
statement being like hey I always do
talk about this and she does she talks
about vote but it was like that okay the
pictures you showed were actual ones if
you went to my Fabio music video plug
and saw it I'm like wearing that makeup
and it looks like me in the video but
like when it's unrecognizable she's a
different person okay that's what I was
saying I'm sorry about that
what I'm saying was Twinkies
I've sold shirts I could say face tune
you know I'm very open about
photoshopping and so on and so forth and
I I'm definitely not as crazy with it
now because it's like
been caught up now and again I've had a
great time doing it I don't know but
everybody doesn't everybody to some
extent Photoshop everyone and their
mother the Instagram yeah I'm not
talking about so does Trisha that's yeah
yeah you know what I'm saying like but I
mean
uh you know what uh you know uh I think
what's good I try to throw in a video
now and again you know I want people to
know it's me wouldn't want to be
unrecognizable yeah you know what I did
I don't I think what's good about you is
that you say you do it right that's
important so people know yeah that
that's what everybody does it yeah you
know do you photoshop Ethan no I've
never photoshopped my uh
was that a stressful time for you like
doing those episodes because I remember
there was always some crazy [ __ ] going
on bro you know what you know what
it didn't feel like it at the time but
coming out of it that it was pretty it
was pretty insane I mean the way it
ended was totally [ __ ] nuts bro I'm
sitting in my house and I start seeing
this stuff come out and I'm and now keep
in mind this is at a time when I'm we're
at War bro right like this is during a
really rough time so I start seeing this
stuff and I'm like whoa dude this this
ship is going down fast bro does she
still does she still command uh a Navy
or an army because when you guys were
together I felt her power surge like
dude she was she would just point get
them and yeah so were those those foot
soldiers that were coming from the H3
Army to Aid because now it seems like
does she still wield the same Zeus like
capabilities no she doesn't but to be
honest with you she's been pretty mellow
yeah that's great she got pregnant I
don't think she really talked any [ __ ]
about anyone that's good to give her
credit yeah do you ever foresee being
cool with Trisha again you know what I
there's some stuff that I just don't
want to say publicly but I'll just say
this
I don't actually hate Trisha like I
understand her she's a complicated
person yeah
in retrospect looking back at that show
I realized that there's a lot of stuff
that she said that I I just trusted and
believed everything she said which maybe
wasn't
the way to do it but the only way to do
that show was to just go like you can't
really like push back on her or you
can't you just have to like go along for
the ride kind of is that hard for you
but you said I do do Photoshop Dan what
do I do what do I Photoshop oh hell no
hold on
oh
I didn't Photoshop that thing oh that's
not real was that originally a real
naked photo you know that I I yeah when
James Charles posted his ass I did uh I
posted my ass a remake of it yeah but
but I don't know what the hell how do
you feel when people come at you with
the oh he's fat you don't give a [ __ ]
huh now I never said anything like that
I would never talk about you know what
and but it's fine because I say so much
vile [ __ ] about people uh but that but I
said lazy fair game lazy comeback it is
especially I I just think it's kind of
funny when you're like trying to make a
have a valid like kind of conversation
about something and it's just like oh
he's fast oh he's a fat ass he's a troll
that just says you lost when you do that
like when somebody says that the biggest
one was uh
when uh I erased my Jordan Peterson
episodes I don't know if you guys know
who that is of course and there was like
a whole conservative meltdown where it
was just like he's fat it was that was
like the whole end oh yeah that was
better yeah yeah basically and so
there's this thing fat uh yeah fat man
bad strong man good basically is what it
comes down to but I don't I don't mind
it it's fine yes
too quickly
is and I like it am I wrong for saying
this why is he always crying
he's he's very understandable no no and
that's what I didn't want you to say he
is about why yes because
I'm holding it back a lot of times too
but he's not well he cries about
Pinocchio and [ __ ]
he's literally but he's like the voice
he's like the the mouthpiece of the
whole movement like how could they he's
got a lot of he's got a lot of like
solid stuff to say though too like he's
not wrong on everything he definitely
says some
interesting stuff yeah okay okay sorry
sorry yeah can I would love to talk
about Jordan
here he is crying yeah he just watched
uh Pinocchio and he just thought man
he's just he just wanted to be a real
boy like well I didn't mean that in a
mean way like I would honestly genuinely
curious like why that always happens
yeah he's his brain is [ __ ] melted
from Xanax like I said I'm not involved
in any of this yeah yeah well now you
are so shout out anyway so let's let's
try to keep it focused here uh uh Tana
so basically and then the tanacon thing
I talked a lot about it but you know do
you hold any uh any Grudge for the
tanacon thing I mean everyone was kind
of talking about that do I hold a grunge
or how do you feel about it how do I
feel do you mean your commentary yeah
you mean yeah my feelings are I think
that if you're gonna hold a convention
and it's gonna fail publicly people I
mean I've spoken on this yeah this dead
horse yeah yeah it's all old stuff
I probably anything you said about
tanacon was very valid okay
um let's watch this clip thank God yeah
she exists no but my commentary is so
over the [ __ ] top here I watched this
back a little bit yesterday and I was
like dude that's [ __ ] I'm just a monster
dude I should be a hater it's like I
mean just listen to this and I'm sorry
in advance why is she popular hey guys
it's Tana sorry you know what's so
stupid about like YouTube like she like
they complete I know I haven't ran about
YouTube but I don't [ __ ] it I don't give
a [ __ ]
who are you talking to why is it I don't
know
okay that YouTube will not even bat an
eye at me or idubbb or any of my friends
that actually have I'm not gonna say
they have talent they deserve shows why
the [ __ ] is it always tana and people
like her who are actually not only the
lowest character but frankly criminals
hater Bros
hello take me away the Romans are really
the the you know looking back comments
don't affect me I mean come on if
comments affected me I wouldn't still be
doing this I
you know shouldn't have that convention
eh you feel me yeah the beard is looking
good those days dude thanks bro yeah you
look super great I was skinny yeah but
you know what changed is I was super
depressed and anxious I think that was
made me a little more angrier and since
then I started you know antidepressants
and this may be very [ __ ] fat what
what do you can you but it's helped a
lot did you say what you take yeah
Lexapro oh yeah oh I'm very familiar
with Lex bro I've taken Lex bro Effexor
everything under the sun yeah I've tried
everything honestly I've been looking at
going back Lexapro is works great for me
but it's I've gained like 86.
so I don't know it's hard does it work
on both problems for you like the
depression dude I feel yeah it's a huge
difference man nice if the conversation
we'll have to have after this yeah yeah
I'm a huge proponent of uh
of medical antidepressants and in
general if needed right yeah
like your therapy too and stuff like
that I did a lot of therapy I'm not
currently in therapy I just meet with my
psychiatrist like once a month I get
shamed for bringing this up on any show
I bring it up on not shame but like
people people that aren't in the space
like and don't get it like don't want to
hear about it but lately I've been
thinking about potentially starting like
a platform that's more focused on it or
or just like even just like a community
that's more focused on it because it's a
big conversation I'm really open about
my problems with uh you know mental
illness and Psychiatry because
there's there was like a stigma for a
long time even on my my software it's
like antidepressants or like being over
subscribed uh prescribed and nobody
actually needs them that's like one
thing and then the other thing is like
you know in your own mind you feel weak
for taking it and it's just such
[ __ ] because it honestly it damn
near saved my life dude taking that [ __ ]
so yeah that's good and it's good that
you talk about that I don't even know
that I agree with like over prescribed
but I think one of the sorry Jeff for
just a quick thing I think one of the
biggest issues why do you apologize no
just because he wants to keep moving I
wanted to talk sometimes but I just know
that you know once he's going he's going
he took that Joe Rogan brain pill before
this and is that what happened oh no no
I just know he wants to stay on the beef
you just took one Alpha Brain yeah just
do it I gave him one loose pill like
because he didn't want he wanted me to
bring the whole bottle oh my God and he
just took it no questions asked just pop
it down all right let's move no we'll
move on from that the reason I say is
because of people that see like show
start texting he'll drift off into the
[ __ ] listen no I can talk mental
health I was gonna chime in and say yeah
I think it's great that we're talking
about it I never ever I got into this
business the [ __ ] around make jokes make
stupid videos make people laugh I
thought that was the best thing you
could do for people is bring joy make
them laugh but after putting out the
documentary getting vulnerable talking
about my mental health that was the
biggest effect I've had on anybody the
most response I've ever got absolutely
and it genuinely helps people that's
what's helping people so I think that's
great but go on Mike sorry no and and to
that point like podcast whatever else I
do these kind of shows are all pale to
the in comparison to the book the book
was my is the biggest thing I'll ever do
for the rest of my life you know what
I'm saying touch a lot on the opiate
epidemic substance abuse and uh and
mental health so
um but all [ __ ] in the head maybe
that's why we get along with BFF yeah
yeah but uh no I was just gonna say I
just think we're it's so weird that
we're still at a point in the psychology
field and the psych uh psychiatric field
where we're like uh picking pills for
people uh and their mental illnesses
like a dart board still yeah how is
how's the air bro like yo today you're
gonna try Effexor today you're gonna try
Wellbutrin like why is there no like
Rhyme or Reason to to it besides like yo
try this this week try this next month
like it just seems like we haven't made
any progress well Psychiatry is weird is
like a weird field where people like
specifically antidepressants and ssris
which is kind of a relatively new one
like Lexapro is kind of a breakthrough
antidepressant for sure and um for some
reason you know some just work better
for people and work worse for worse so I
think what they generally do is just
cycle through starting with like the
ones that work the most which is usually
Lexapro I suppose the main and then just
go through like down to Prozac and stuff
but I don't think in the end of the day
they don't really know a lot about the
brain yet like even still you know it's
the final frontier people say spaces but
I think the human brain is the final
frontier to be honest we just don't know
anything [ __ ] did well they can't they
can't cut it open and close it back up
that's the problem well and we just have
no view we have no like idea around uh
Consciousness and like the mom yeah
Consciousness and elon's trying to put a
chip in there now no thanks would you
try that out to be one of the first I'm
not letting Elon touch anything in my
body bro what did it but he put the chip
in his own head and prove you know he's
doing perfect concept to me you know
yeah that's fair no I turned on Elon
Musk man I don't I'm not a fan I feel
like everyone has really he used to do
no wrong running the right right now in
the meme Community yeah he's very
popular
uh okay so Tana that that's pretty much
it you know and uh but the thing that's
special about you is that you know you
never said a bad thing about me and so
I'm sorry for the body shaming and uh
everything you know that I said and when
I said I'm not sorry just to be clear a
b you know I was being facetious uh and
I think I've clarified now maybe uh I
mean have I clarified your satisfaction
maybe maybe yeah as the representative
of the Tana Community we accept okay bro
a b gotta be pulling chicks dude he's
married that's his wife oh sorry well he
pulled it
I was right yeah yeah you're right dude
he's like P Davidson bro he's like got
the whole swag going on and everything
thank you and I said Poland just because
I know you guys are saying Poland last
week yeah yeah I don't usually say that
I appreciate it
anyways can you change my shirt do you
want to apologize that was a little
chauvinistic no no yeah okay I don't I
think you're good at what you do
whatever I mean
I mean the things you've thrown at me
because it's just we're two different
Realms like I I always just kind of
looked at it as like H3 is gonna hate on
me for no matter what yeah might as well
just live my life and yeah
you're a Slayer
Slayer too man
um you're a slave Queenie
what's happening
um there you go there you have it okay
yeah so this is it we swatched the beef
yeah by the way I don't I think it was
one-sided beef you know
like you're never really angry so maybe
I should be the ones well yeah put your
arm in there maybe now you can sleep at
night without letting your hatred for
Tana Mojo keep you up well that was
never a pain never thought about you
that much that's her pinky in the mouth
I feel like Jeff I feel like you could
have done one piece of beef dude like we
really had to do it okay fine here we go
do you want to bring this home as a
memorabilia or I wouldn't want to eat it
might get back to my twinkie days
nice
once it goes on the Vise it's done we
can never bring it up again
you should have to delete Any Trail of
the evidence off the internet now oh no
that'd be like that'd be a good idea
you still get the revenue from front of
me yeah right delete my episode
right at this point
was H3 really the or Frenemies I mean
where that leaked like for the first
time yeah well then somebody uh somebody
was on the beach and they had a video
and they started uh trying to Blackmail
me on the beach from the excavator day
yeah a random person was trying to
Blackmail you yeah they were trying they
were saying they were selling it to
Insider or something and uh what the
[ __ ] and once a video is on the internet
you know it gets screen recorded and
reposted you can be taken down so I
started a little group chat with like my
Die Hard supporters and I'm so grateful
they [ __ ] took everything down they
would flag the [ __ ] out of it and they
would get pulled down it was stressful
at the time because I was like trying to
work on this doc to tell the story the
right way the way I wanted to which
still wasn't the right way but at the
time time I thought it was and yeah they
helped out a lot so that that was a cool
shout out to the side but if you regret
about the documentary
um the story was told
not the right way I would have liked
what would you have changed about it
uh
the priority should have been to tell my
story the honest truth and not sugar
coat it to you feel it was too
sugar-coated yeah because at the time
you know my whole audience was his whole
audience right and
it's scary that's hard yeah what am I
gonna do go against everybody right you
know and I I was around that life for a
couple years and I saw where he was at
his Peak and it was like the [ __ ]
Beatles it was insane yeah absolutely so
now you want me to be like all right I
just got [ __ ] up and this is the real
story I think you know he was trying to
fling me off for a prank and now I'm
just gonna change the whole story even
the day after I got out of the hospital
when he called he called uh one of the
Kardashians or something and he was like
look at what this idiot did or some [ __ ]
like that and I was like yo what the
[ __ ] right this is what you think
happened right this is the narrative
you're trying to spread so it's already
manipulation from this part and
I was just blind at the time you know I
was like
no this is the way I have to handle it
because I still want a career I get that
honestly life that's scary to go up
against dubrick right up right out the
game what is that duber that's my mom
she said duber and that's what I was
saying yeah and then I put out little
feelers later on I'm like you know a
year and a half in nine surgeries in
barely talk to the kid anymore and then
um they just stopped even hitting me up
in general like I would go get surgery I
Stitch shut and I'm like just [ __ ]
dealing with this [ __ ] and then he puts
out the well I started posting little
things like let me make fun of the
hairline yeah to see what type of person
it really was because I was sensing it
in my head and
I was like well and then obviously you
guys helped out like a lot of people
were making me think like all right I
can't actually do something here so then
I started doing that and then
they put out a podcast where he had saw
a meme that he saw after the accident
happened we're in the hospital he's the
only one that's there and I remember him
I don't remember a lot from that day but
I remember that
and he's like oh oh [ __ ] dude look you
sent me this [ __ ] meme like this
thing and
it was like he found you know an alibi
or something so the evidence he was he
showed on his screen he's like yo Jeff
said that to me podcast and blame me for
the whole thing and it's like all right
oh yeah it was a meme about like an
accident or something right yeah there's
some guy on an excavator swinging around
in a rope yeah and he was like yo this
is an omission of guilt or something
yeah yeah yeah exactly like I like it
was my idea yeah right right right right
right right like it matters anyway yeah
yeah at the end of the day I was
like I remember I I got I can't get into
too much because it's evidence that I
I'm yeah yeah you know you're in
litigation Amber Heard live streams you
can react to those that's good views for
me I'm rooting for that I'm pushing for
that I have some stuff yeah yeah I don't
want to go back and forth on the
internet too much and also the Lord said
not to yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Mom's the Word yeah
but let's get into Mike huh okay so so
anyway yeah Tana uh uh best friend Tana
is my best friend now
oh I never heard [ __ ] boss you guys are
best friends Well for now okay yeah I
mean
that's what I was just saying the
besties no
body's wearing the hat with me huh and
you went backwards with it no my no
that's my other hat oh you took it off
yeah it just didn't fix not we're not
BFFs yet
oh you put it on when you think the
moment's right okay it'll be a nice
moment yeah yeah if you feel the
moment's right we don't want to come in
here and just dick right act like
everything's all right I know that's how
I started out the show but I'm at their
energy now and you know what yeah we're
[ __ ] standing up for the [ __ ] you
said what do I I have brain damage I
forgot everything you said bad about me
do you really now it's rekindling now
it's all coming back up yeah you did say
I had a [ __ ] uh Cyclops eye yeah yeah
no yeah we'll get into that yeah no I
made fun of your eye quite a bit for
sure yeah we'll get there Tana that's
why I was you know it's all here it's
all here okay hey I'm not looking for
dick riding either maybe rides my dick
enough for everybody
hey B my man yeah I'll take some of that
no that's not true Amy's not the dick
Raider it's Zach yeah and I love him for
that I love you too yeah I love you
buddy Zach's got great hair thank you
Jeff that's what mine's gonna look like
after my turkey hair growing out real
long it's growing it's growing a little
bit yeah it's just I haven't had a
haircut in a while so I wore a hat today
because I haven't had like this anyways
uh what do you hate me yeah you want to
talk about your hair more no no no no no
all right so let's move on to Mike um
all right here we go now this boy this
is this actually just turned into like a
podcast about me being a dick
that's basically the whole threat where
did you think it was gonna go like it's
like I kind of knew that that was the
direction but like now that I'm talking
about everything it's like unrecipitable
I may not have it I I may not have any
fans left after this
came in here like [ __ ] everything you
know it's all good it is what it is play
that Godfather music where's the sound
bites today you could play it for him
yeah I can get it you gonna hit that
Mike you take this one up
we come to the studio to have a
conversation with you
we know about your outstanding beef hmm
with the star that has came games are
like sorry got me at all for you
an olive branch I know it was you afraid
you sit down with you and discuss what
the options are
and buy options
I won't get into it right but there's a
good chance that we walk out of here
today as an alliance okay good the Upper
East Side Brooklyn Queens and Staten
Island right sitting down at the table
breaking bread together yes what do you
say nothing like that that sounds good
I like that Fredo sound bite I was gonna
come in here and kiss you on the lips
and start off so
um dope tell Cody to go home Cody's
outside tell Cody to go home
Cody gave me the directions to get down
here
a message
what's up what have we done listen
Michael you come here today
to break bread with respect to Italian
culture
do you know my children are seven
percent Italian forget about it scum
[ __ ]
yeah
just this half
the half with the good eye you know
you've seen a good Fellas when he he's
like I told him I told my mother you're
Jewish Only the Good half
that's what I do that's what I do and we
got my friend Cody outside in case this
goes sideways
when you were doing that voice while I
was crying bro I was laughing it's so
funny because if you think that the
majority of [ __ ] that like anyone in
this room has had to say about any of us
were at home like [ __ ] [ __ ]
but a lot of times I'm sitting back like
yo this is funny yeah it is funny and
he's making fun of me when he's doing it
I love it yeah thank you for saying that
you know appreciate that we're just so
let's see let's go let's focus on the
the mic now I watched this clip back and
I'll be honest
it's private I gotta say it's pretty
vile and I don't think I would say
anything like this today uh but here I'm
just gonna play for you guys and
apologies in advance
she does the craziest [ __ ] like she'll
take like a 20 yard dick that's like 10
feet wide 20 yards no I'm just no penis
that's impossible it's physically
impossible like she she'll take like she
does like the craziest porn you can
imagine with like dicks like tons of
dicks I'm talking about Lana yeah
fully out of every hole and all that
and I don't I just don't understand how
can you please a woman like that after
that she's actively taking like 20 dicks
in her veg that same day well yeah I
know and I remember and I remember and
this was one of the first times where I
I know where I like wanted to so you
tweeted at me about this correct yeah
and I remember I had right off the bat
had Hela support right like she was like
I had no support on right on this one
right no nobody nobody has my back so
let me so let me break into it for a
second so like
do you ever find yourself when someone
has something to say about you you're
like strangely unoffended or unaffected
by it but when someone has something to
say about your significant other yeah of
course your mom your dad you're ready to
go to [ __ ] town bro yeah you're mad
and that's the kind of person that I am
and I like that was a really vulnerable
time for me because it gave people that
wanted to get under my skin the ability
to do so because they knew exactly where
to attack and I was very vulnerable at
that time I was very affected by a lot
of that stuff dude and and you know I
would come up with a million different
like like this tweet a million different
ways to combat it but it was an
internalized battle I had to deal with
when you say you were insecure with it
you mean just with like the relationship
or or the issue is that Lana Amara at
the time was very very
kind of felt a lot of Shame and a lot of
things about that part of her life and
about that industry that she wasn't
proud of and and that industry is a
disgusting place a disgusting place and
there was a lot of things similar to the
scenes that you were discussing and
talking about these crazy scenes that
they're actually coerced or like
underhandedly pushed into doing yo oh I
don't want to do that scene well you
don't you don't do that scene you don't
do a scene for the next six months
because they can't tell you
oh like they can't say that in like a
specific way like yo if you don't do
that scene you're fired because that
breaks the law but like you know like
this hey maybe you don't do that scene
maybe we don't see you again for six
months you know we got other girls that
it's a really [ __ ] up place a toxic
Place yeah and so it was something that
she was just very just not okay with and
I was aware of how not okay she was with
it so when other people were like openly
talking about it openly mocking it it
really hurt me you know what I'm saying
I'm really upset me yeah but um but yeah
I didn't have any trouble with any foot
soldiers on that one I think you got no
nobody had my back on that one you know
looking back I think what I in a way
meant to say was that I don't know how
you could
like having sex with her is intimidating
right sure like no yeah maybe that maybe
what you said yes that's what I meant
nothing to do with like I don't know why
I had to go down like the badge being
blasted and all that [ __ ] because I know
that's stupid that's all [ __ ] stupid
ass misogyny lame disgusting by the way
shame on me [ __ ] just just in essence I
think what you were saying is like is
the the question is a legitimate
question like how do you intend on
pleasing someone that has had sex with
men of this size men of these different
all these different I think it's just
it's intimidating right like you're
[ __ ] a uh an Olympic Athlete yes yes
you know do you want the answer to it
yeah okay so well sure if you're I mean
I'm not no no no yeah I will come in
here with the answer I'm less just
quickly and by the way yeah I like Lana
like she seems like a great person man
honestly super nice and again and it
didn't deserve it uh that that kind of
words sometimes I just try to be funny
and it's alive
I've gotten a lot better at censoring
myself I think in the past couple years
well I think also like people see what
uh adult film stars do and they then
make the assumption that they're
completely okay with being like very
graphic and discussion about it and like
that makes sense like that that
connection makes sense so I wasn't like
wasn't that it was definitely like going
overboard but um the answer to what
you're saying and I'm I'm a little bit
less affected by [ __ ] like this but
um the the answer is women create a
psychological and a mental bond with
their lovers that doesn't exist in a uh
recreational sexual sexual atmosphere
and so like I hate to burst the bubble
of a lot of porn viewers out there but
like the majority of porn stars aren't
enjoying the sex that they're having on
so they're just not it's just the fact
of the matter they're doing it it's work
it's as enjoyable as you know
but another like a nine to five for
someone else right like you'll have to
go and I have to go and do this yeah
it's my job and then a lot of them go
home and they have uh passionate
intercourse with a lover and actually
glean some sort of meaningful
satisfaction right right so that's my
Long View yeah I thought he was gonna
say I'm actually the [ __ ] man no
that's not but that's interesting Mike
you brought up a good point you're
saying that because it's on camera the
connection it's all [ __ ] what about
this here
we're on camera here squashing our beach
what are we gonna do we're gonna hang
out after this
you know to be honest with you I would I
would go as far as saying that the
conversation we have outside of this may
be more
maybe yeah it's called
bfffffs yeah but we're on camera this is
fake what is it I don't think I mean I I
feel I feel like when I'm on camera are
you having an existential crisis yeah
I'm easily I personally feel it on a
crane
we have a Gatsby I don't know what that
is I'm sure you can injure yourself on
that pretty good you know no I think
we're getting somewhere I'm just I think
I'm just trying to break up the I know
what you mean though this was our first
I personally feel that um
I'm I'm you know genuine on camera even
if I take [ __ ] too far sometimes but
we're not [ __ ] no we're not [ __ ]
but we can do you know what frauding is
fraudage oh you guys don't know that
it's when you you know what that is I'm
the only one [ __ ] this isn't gonna look
good this one dude sticks together and
like their dicks basically touch I
thought it was docking is it docking one
too well isn't docking we put the
foreskin yeah is that different oh no
that's a whole set that's a whole
different procedure how come me and you
not do you know like what Cleveland
Steamers are and all that [ __ ] like you
follow like that Urban Dictionary type
actually done was that when you [ __ ] on
a girl's back or so yeah or the chest
right is that what that is somebody yeah
that's enough chest oh yeah that's
popular in Cleveland I don't know what
it is that Cleveland has to do with it
maybe Cleveland just is like
maybe just as a shitty Cleveland rocks
you know what the last person I was with
in Cleveland I just want to say this
quickly I was at a um a restaurant there
and I ran into Oliver tree oh yeah and
um I I missed a lot no I missed a lot of
the stuff with you guys I'm just saying
you didn't shake his hand because he has
monkey pox current this was just not too
long ago yeah no he has he has open
wounds but dude he was he had some
really [ __ ] up stuff to say about and
honestly like at the time like me and
you hadn't swasta beef yet yeah some of
the stuff he said about you about you
why about your wife
um
recently yeah I want to know did you
catch that because he talked a lot of
crap yeah that was though you want to
see what and you can read this text
okay let's do this I got a text from him
today as well I'm gonna read this to you
guys
he says I just want you to know before
going into it don't believe anything
those guys say they're all pathological
oh that's interesting because I got you
want me including me he said he said he
said don't believe anything Ethan says
he's a notorious liar he said that to
you yeah oh wait wait Jeff Jeff I hadn't
opened this one but read the top text
from him and I just said back and then
he said a bunch of terrible stuff he
repeated what he said in the barbershop
that I had to cut read this yeah it was
light read the top text that he sent to
me today
um don't believe anything Ethan says
he'll try to lie to you like he does to
all his idiot fans uh this is from
Oliver
so Oliver tree you got you know about
him I do it was in his music video
yesterday oh really I wonder if that was
a dig at you wonderful you got monkey
butt yeah you didn't touch him did you
uh no was he sick because he just let me
ask you a question because he just
canceled his fire Fest in San Diego he's
just did he seem sick to you on the
shirt
he was burning a second not show he says
he can't talk he has like nodes in his
lungs or not Long's throat yeah he's
[ __ ] lying you know what happened he
didn't sell enough tickets at that
stadium and he was embarrassed so oh
that's what they're saying about Jake
Jake's thing do you know anything about
that I don't know I think that would be
what happened I think Hashim didn't make
I don't know but but um so I saw him in
Cleveland yeah and it was I mean dude it
was gnarly I don't know like you know
you know he's you know what he's oh this
is the second time so this is the second
time
I had seen them in the past month yeah
he's been going out doing the circuit I
don't know what the [ __ ] he's been up to
I go to hide because you know I go out
and I I Network and have fun and stuff
like that he's that high he's that high
you guys are the same age hey hey hey I
don't know what height is hey bucket
bucket up it's just interesting I'm just
putting out there I'm not shaming anyone
I'm just throwing it out there last time
your audience try to twist my words and
say that I was I was fat shaming you I
was age shaming you oh but it's all I
said was you are younger I think it's
silly if if my fans get mad at you
saying oh yeah I didn't remember you
said it's okay you implied that he looks
better than me no yes you know but it's
fine it was like this is yeah this is
what happens if you say something and
then everybody backs you up I was saying
you're not out at Hyde you have kids you
have a different lifestyle more
respectable lifestyle some would say and
he's saying he's out at high networking
yeah what does networking mean man come
on what we all know what networking
means we see his Instagram
we see all the chicks on his Instagram
wait so are you done yeah go for it I
see well hold on sure I'll just never
say this um you did say you guys are the
same age but anyway you it's okay I'm
not offense you should add that I've
made fun of you I've made fun of your
eyes so much I was like guys how are you
gonna get mad at Jeff like it's all good
it's like I've never made fun of your
appearance ever ever said I looked old
no but it's fine you guys are I was just
seeing you were leading into it okay
whatever you want to say okay you can
throw the meat in the vice
we'll get to you we'll get to Jeff can I
yeah go ahead so he tells me he I guess
has been spending time with uh nelk
and and he said that the following week
he was going to Croatia to meet Tate
top G they told me they're doing a song
about you Andrew Tate's gonna be on it
this and you this I'm not I'm not your
way at all either no I know I I believe
I have pictures or videos of it too and
I think he I don't know if you know this
but I think Keem was doing a charity
dinner in Rochester and he said he'd
bought a he he Oliver had he bought a
1500 plate at King's Charity Dinner you
know how I know you're lying
because people pay keemstar to stay away
from their charity events okay
I'm staying out of your your guys listen
words
and keemstar teamed up there's a diss
track coming your way we're just giving
you a heads up this is it let's move on
okay you know by the way you want to
know what have you heard you want to
know how pathetic Oliver is he goes
he goes hey if you feel so bad for me
maybe you can mention in the Pod and
plug my tour [ __ ] you bro and you did
idiot you just did it kind of just did
yeah I did yeah
just don't breathe next to them really
close he's he's just an [ __ ] I don't
know what to say he talks [ __ ] he goes
in his shows and he goes [ __ ] Ethan
Klein [ __ ] Ethan Klein and it's like
it's whack yeah fun no at the end Oliver
tree's a piece of [ __ ] he's a piece of
[ __ ] I don't know what he's talking
about yeah yours is real yeah mine's
real yeah he's a business partner of
mine we have a company together called
good luck slime and drink slime oh yeah
are you in on that yeah yeah I'm a
partner good for you man it's not it's
about time you get paid from that
[ __ ] doing something with what's his
face we make money we make money he's a
good he's Logan's a great partner
I missed that what did he just say it's
about time it's about time you make some
money
you're outside in Turkey hustling for
15K upgrade of a partner can he be
I get it
but thanks for letting me know oh do you
know what that's from Michael please
someone called Logan to tell them
I'm just gonna talk about yeah yeah
someone called Logan to say hey bro this
was like during the height of the
pandemic Tanner Fox was in him oh yeah
he's like bro we were together all
weekend and I have covet I'm so sorry
and then Logan said
bad Jack
yeah it's so funny
but anyways immune system probably we're
good it's a damn superhero see yeah no
where we all survived we had a game plan
we did a rehearsal on the way here to
see how things would go we back each
other up we got a code word for when we
walk if that comes that time he's really
good at the fake Epic
we all walk that Jeff wittick's a good
liar audience just like Oliver said
seems like it's starting to stack up
against you but I'm winning the polls
pal 52 percentage numbers don't lie
you're Arizona right now you're about to
be [ __ ] recounted yeah the wrong
state of Pennsylvania I think Arizona
was in the recounts I don't know but it
was close enough I mean it was
definitely the last poll was within you
know
um Pennsylvania
dumps so anyway
uh so Mike the other thing is basically
this one you know
this one I don't know it's a little hard
to bring up no I'm good with anything
okay so so so
I'm ready I'm ready to walk yeah get
ready to walk bro
get ready to walk on this one
hey guys what's up it's me Mike here to
send some love and camaraderie to the
ding dong telegram team I know you guys
have been busting your ass to make sure
that the hottest newest coin of 2021 is
Dink doink with the hottest
functionality and all of the most
built-in techniques tactics and
capabilities
is cleared to be the hottest [ __ ]
Coin ever okay I just wanted to keep up
the good work and if you guys do
everything that you're doing right now
even more exponentially we can go to the
top of this whole [ __ ] Market dude
you keep going
when you watch that video is there one
second three no no pause it please
no
not do it
all right
no can you kill the video not even the
you no video I don't want that okay so
no video either I don't know all right
yo let me ask you a question when you
watch that video of me is there any
moment of that where you're like wow
this seems serious like no you're
obviously being tongue-in-cheek a [ __ ]
bro okay let me explain let me explain
to you very quickly
yo
I'm doing this this [ __ ] thing
absolutely no explanation it's a it's a
[ __ ] idea that talks [ __ ] about the
crypto Community can you send a video to
me that I'm gonna post for the 15 devs
in this telegram group chat and that's
it two days later the things [ __ ]
viral I mean I'm like bro it was awesome
[ __ ] [ __ ] is gonna see this and
they're gonna think this is a real
[ __ ] thing now well but I never know
let me say sarcastic I have never
in any of my wallets except that a dink
doink coin except at any kind of payment
for dink doing there was no money made
there I've never been involved in even a
semblance of a scam crypto scam you
didn't bring it you didn't profit from
ding dong okay good God bless
building off of that coin how was tits
coin no hold on a second go to tick
point after building building off of
that yeah
just to overarch a macro statement
because I know you're including you know
[ __ ] it I'll just leave it there
yeah we don't scam I've never scammed
anyone before Logan cares extremely
deeply about his audience loves his
audience loves his brand doesn't have to
[ __ ] scam to make money that's what I
would think that's what's so confusing
about it he didn't make [ __ ] nobody
made money on dink dunk dude yo you're
in trouble that crypto [ __ ]
it's how what's interesting is that it's
virtually zero it's the same as Luna
and by the way by the way it probably
was your fault actually I lost a
financial sponsorship a financial
product sponsor sponsorship as a result
of that video going live
yeah give me the Godfather listen well
no no listen it wasn't that much it was
it was 35k are you gonna pay my friend
half the money
otherwise Cody want to be a visit oh how
much was the deal 35k 35. we got that
real Italian doing The Godfather it was
so they saw it so they saved my friend
here 17-5 otherwise Cody's gonna come
down here every couple days to collect
oh that's coming [ __ ] man listen I'm not
responsible for him he's no I'm just
saying it was wild did you do know about
that hey problem solved no I mean he's
gone he's out of there dogs he's out of
the country yeah he's got you back now
yeah he's on your team now he's your
problem I'm team Cody yeah yeah did you
know about that I saw it it was mine I
couldn't believe that I mean I didn't
send anybody anything I went to gay
community and he got in and he was
taking photos of my [ __ ] house he's
good at stuff like that figuring things
out what are we talking about yeah I
know really happy yeah yeah it was he
went to Logan's that time too when you
were when you were talking so me and
Jeff had a Thing Once by the way like
this oh yeah this isn't the first
episode of BFFs we beef goes on oh yeah
yeah really oh yeah well well I don't
hold on I don't know if that's if that
part's public of what yeah he said it on
his pockets you want to fight let's [ __ ]
him it's because of why though right
what happened because David made the
joke on the podcast uh yeah David made a
joke uh [ __ ] I don't even remember bro
no David went on the set of impulsive
during a party we were having at Logan's
house without us being there and made a
tasteless joke okay we don't have to
repeat what it was but it was a
tasteless show Logan what was he said
footage of it and no and saw that he
made that joke because Logan had oh he
made a forest joke two Logan's cameraman
yeah did we not even we don't even talk
about the forest no it's no well I mean
we're not gonna today but like yeah it's
a topic of discussion I mean dude he'll
he'll tell you it's the yeah no no
changes I mean dude think about let me
ask you a question
let's let's let's cap the other welcome
back thank you thanks for coming so so
are you comfortable do you need
something to drink I'm chilling thank
you I just want to make sure you're
happy and
you're driving
yeah no we don't have to yeah
David David uh David made this joke and
Jeff so so I was Logan's
at the time you know gutter [ __ ]
Dirtbag friend he's dobrik's dirt things
have changed for you well we were I
would consider it Mike's a really good
friend of mine yeah he looked out but
you said something about being a better
well we come from me and Jeff come from
the same time right and we come from
whatever right yeah so so I he he's
expressing his distaste for Logan having
distaste with David's comment and Logan
and David are having a very YouTubey
beef and me and Jeff get on FaceTime and
and it turns into like uh yo you want to
[ __ ] go down this route [ __ ] I'll
come to your [ __ ] house right now
what did I say I think you're not gonna
like how this ends I said this is gonna
end really bad for both of us I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm ready and I was doubling
down too I said you could beat the [ __ ]
out of me we could share a [ __ ]
hospital bed we'll share the ambulance
it's fine let me know
I said I like that and then we became
best friend after a while sometimes I
gotta say sometimes you take [ __ ] too
far yeah like you always turn you go
like I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill everybody you don't say that yeah
you don't say that but you're like I'll
[ __ ] like like
I was too quick to do all that yeah it's
a character trait I mean you never you
never heard anyone
that I know about well he probably has
in the past but yeah not that I know
about
no you're just discussing things okay
what are we gonna do insert myself no no
no no I just want to make sure you're
comfortable I'm happy I'm so comfortable
I'm so happy how's your mouth feel hurts
like a [ __ ] yeah experts helped it with
the pain yeah but I didn't want to come
here off the Norcos [ __ ] up yeah yeah
damn
you want to ask me how my eye feels
how's your eye feel Jeff I don't really
like complaining about myself you don't
like to talk about it yeah I get that
I'll jump quickly towards the Logan
stuff because you guys have had a very
tumultuous like time lots of History
damn like it's like one of the biggest
right like you guys have had a you've
had a lot to say and I just I'm just
curious I'm just curious because you
asked about the forest and you asked
about like if we talk about it or not
and like
like let me ask you this question when
you compare the the lp that is now to
the lp that was prior to that what do
you what do you see well I'm not gonna
lie that WWE shit's pretty epic I saw
that I was like damn I can't hate on
this it's crazy the flips how he's a big
guy flipping like that like those guys
trained for like decades to be able to
do that [ __ ] I don't even know how he's
just naturally athletic and like soup
and just a incredible I mean it's been
his goal since day one to be the biggest
Entertainer sure in the world you know
yeah but I just like it goes back to
that yeah he's matured yeah of course
he's matured yeah the only thing the
only thing I can really say bad about uh
Logan at this point is just that
you know the crypto stuff is sometimes a
little [ __ ] they think the link
honestly is probably the the thing I
mean here for example here we are the
Godfathers you give me a dog
uh Jeff has a cat
I got like paper clips because that
whole thing I never even got anything I
got lost money bro what is it every like
what's up what is that a spring it's the
dink don't like mascot oh Logan Paul
voiced it and everything oh okay yeah
he's the one that sings dig dunk is my
favorite oh damn that was made just now
huh they got our exactly that's what cam
does
good work is it funny out [ __ ] like this
is like the worst thing that could ever
like bro like imagine him calling me
about this like yeah
like yo we have this stupid thing where
we make a cartoon about some dumb [ __ ]
all of a sudden I'm losing sponsorships
I'm still here
bro like dude like what the [ __ ] I feel
worse for the poor kid that [ __ ]
thought it was funny right and starting
made it and he's like yo here's a funny
idea now I don't know who the [ __ ] it is
but yeah
no no I mean it pissed off us bro like
[ __ ] dude look at that let me let me
look at the end of the day that song's
kind of fire it is yeah it's super
catchy we all singing in the office like
yeah we'd get down with that song like
that song will live forever because it's
so fire
you're right just what I'm saying is
back to the thing about like speaking in
absolutes without having absolute facts
like this is another one of those
situations like there just is there's
nothing there they're just never the kid
the kid has since day one wanted to
build community his new project is a
great [ __ ] problem somebody sold the
issue let me put it this way there's a
lot of people involved in projects a lot
it's not just one person and a and a
project there's somewhere there's devs
and the logo and basically he owned half
the project no shot the kid doesn't have
[ __ ] it doesn't have time to do
anything what he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about any of this never never made a
dollar on any of these projects not one
[ __ ] dollar dude how do I want you
zero how don't you piss at all through
these episodes I guess you know I I have
a sensitive bladder I piss a lot but
during the show I think I just put it in
a vault okay man yeah I'm worried about
your hydration no I'm drinking I'm
drinking I mean I get in trouble for
pissing on impulsive that's one thing I
will say about about LP he does not have
any patience for small bladders really
a lot of times when you feel like you're
craving a snack a lot of times you just
dehydrated you need water that's a good
point it'll quench your appetite that's
that's actually really good advice
hungry and then you won't be hungry yeah
because you get that sensation of being
full I know it doesn't taste as good but
you slam that water down room temp
sometimes I gotta be like an attic for
food do you know what I mean like he
looks at me
bro that's that's me all right come on I
did put the beef back in all right I'm
sorry bring it back I'm actually just
[ __ ] but I'm not getting very many
words in so when I can you know do you
know what I'm talking about Tana you
ever feel like you're addicted to food
yeah all right
no but I all of it yeah I don't really
do any drugs these days I feel like a
food addict yeah I do I can't [ __ ]
control myself look at me
I used to be skinny not that long ago
you guys saw
I have a cheeseburger review Channel
Ethan I am you look good bro yeah well
do have you do you ever get a chance to
work out or would you consider doing it
it's so powerful dude it's
no I don't mean it like that yes
but I know you're you exercise a lot
it's therapeutic for you right yeah I
[ __ ] hate I run a lot after the
mental and that's good and um God bless
you I'm jealous for that that's probably
a feeling of productivity you know I
feel like I did something hard yeah I
don't feel like a loser right you know
but we can talk about mental issues all
the time and I I think we stick to the
beef we want to get okay we'll stick to
the beef I do I do Health talks and and
stuff like that all the time you are
skinny Legend you're trying to keep your
body fat down so you look just no no no
I got a I had a little basal cell skin
cancer right here I couldn't work out at
all I have stitches in right now wait it
was melanoma or whatever or basal cell
what is basil it's a form of skin cancer
sounds like a plant but I don't like to
complain about about myself too much
that's no it's I'm just curious I'm 100
free wait is it super bad snipped it off
no it's just I go out in the sunlight go
out and run every day with my shirt off
that was what I do everything
and now he oils up his stomach too
no did you wear sunscreen when you're on
I wasn't now I do yeah now I've been
running with shirts on but yeah I
couldn't lift weights I'm a little
skinnier right now than usual but I'm
gonna get I'm gonna take this meat home
eat it all again that's all good I'm
glad someone's gonna I'm gonna eat it
all good all right so Mike we had the we
had the these beefs that we talked about
I never read your Tweet I'll just read
it for posterity's sake [ __ ] you said
well no you mean you got me dear H3 I
saw your segment about Lana on today's
upload I'm not gonna get into your
disgusting rhetoric I like you rhetoric
is like oh [ __ ] he's going there
as it's your brand dispute hate
disguised as comedy it's both
there's no disguise it's in plain sight
yeah you know but she retired three
years ago if you're gonna call yourself
a podcast host at least do some research
yeah I thought I thought it was
interesting that you focused on the
retired part and not the blast no
because you were saying it as if it was
happening like in real time I see I see
yeah but like dude like earlier today
she got a 30-foot [ __ ] like yeah yeah
okay so yeah not even 30 feet it's 20
yards 20 yards that's a lot
yeah bro okay are you guys mentally
Imagining the size of that penis it's
tough that's so big that's a fifth of a
football field yeah yeah no that's
stupid like dude Mandingo and like Dread
and those guys they're like not even
close the best of them couldn't take
that no but I'll tell you what I
apologize to Lana I think she deserves
an apology for that stuff you know well
I'll have her come spin the crank then
you're gonna say anything to me what the
[ __ ] well so and well
we talked about
um you uh the financing the house with
the nft that was awesome
that was recent anything I do that has a
[ __ ] sponsor says sponsored in it so
so did you really lend that a board ape
into that protocol got a loan but and
still haven't even paid the loan back
believe it or not I still have to pay
the loan I don't have the ape how much
should they loan you 200 200 that way
yeah and do you think it it's like that
for everybody or just you so they offer
uh arcade it's oh [ __ ] you don't have to
how do they make money from having a
[ __ ] nft they run a uh it's the same
as any other lending protocol so they
have there's an interest rate on it and
so you have a lot of nft yes and so you
would so they would give you a loan and
you would pay back with a couple points
but that's just collateral yeah yeah
they'll give you a loan again see I mean
dude listen as much [ __ ] as we talk or
as you guys talking we do too about like
the crypto on the nft space it is a it
is a potentially meaningful field that
could yield something in the future yeah
I agree it's just it's so full of
Charlotte right now it's so it's yeah
listen I'm with you and that's why and
that's why when you when those comments
were coming out it was especially
[ __ ] painful because one it
interfered for me personally with
stuff that I was doing on the non-crypto
side but also for LP like once again not
to just keep saying this but he doesn't
he does he's a LP is a straightforward
[ __ ] person do you guys acknowledge
that it didn't look shady I think that
you had I think that there were stuff
that looked Shady yeah I not for me
because I see you know you never you
were involved you just got wrangled into
it to making of it and I think he did
too you know what I mean like he wasn't
come on he was involved I'm not here to
LIT again
okay okay but I know but here here's
what I'll say just one more like last
macro point I know him as a person and I
know he would never do that okay I just
know that for a [ __ ] fact all right
this I apologize for Mike during
Frenemies the steamies we did nominate
you for douchebag of the year didn't I
didn't I win no no no
um I don't think so I didn't mean to
even win huh did I win I don't think you
were nominated oh okay you looked at me
I was like no yeah I went into this no
no no let's see 20. let's take a look at
the nominee shall we
biggest douchebag of 2020. yeah Mike
wearing a dress he's wearing a dress
wearing a dress doing whip it oh this
got you in trouble right the dress oh
you got George George took more heat
from it oh it birthed the major problem
yeah yeah
what what the [ __ ] were they thinking
there's no one on the show who's more
relatable than me
I'm sorry Ethan you are a piece oh I
think keemstar he takes a dub on any
category he's a [ __ ] Garden garbage
everybody tweet yeah but you guys you
want to see who won against Charles
Jeffree Star Jack yeah that's the whole
impulsive podcast like um yes Jack is a
joke for the record Jack we love you so
Jack knows Trisha insisted that we
include that and I thought well biggest
douchebag of the Year
Jack is so nice
think anything he just made a video
he didn't even show yeah
I wouldn't be mad if Mike won he's very
douchey I mean he's nice he's a nice guy
open the envelope uh I'm gonna go Jack's
homes oh my God all right let's get a
drum roll biggest back in 2020.
here we go
and the winner
goes
is it Mike
yeah yeah I think he I think he took it
by a mile you guys [ __ ] hate each
other dude can I ask you like a couple
questions about that like yeah like dude
what like what goes through your mind
that you want to keep like engaging with
it I think it's just funny
it's [ __ ] funny because he's such a
and I would ask him the same question
it's like what are you guys getting I I
guess like what do they say like dirty
launcher pays the bills like just share
an ambulance already get it over with
you know dude you guys don't know what
actually what is no we don't know I
don't wanna I don't want to get to the
vet yeah I have no idea I remember you
even asked me I was like bro I have no
idea about your beefs you know look at
how many you have how am I gonna follow
that well me and him have gotten into it
multiple times on Twitter over over [ __ ]
like
his some of his stances on on politic
mental health it hurts it hurts and I've
and me and him me and him are cordial
and and you know like he'll text me and
ask me questions and you know he's he
hasn't I'll say this he hasn't done
anything the way that he does stuff to
you to me so I can't really say anything
but like he has some takes on Twitter
that make me hurt like I feel painful
yeah you know what I'm saying and so
like I just I'll always just Tweet back
and I hope that maybe I can affect his
thought process in some way death to all
Jews yeah yeah he said that he said who
was that was that oh
wait he said I I had her to come from
that direction Dan did you say that no
no he he was on Twitter once and he goes
everybody go write Ethan on Twitter
that's all she is I mean like dude's out
of control you guys were nasty you guys
this was different times right like you
guys were like it was like last week
you guys were [ __ ] ruthless back in
the day bro you were too
the thing is about keemstar is that
the dude was like trying to ruin my life
like literally for years and I never
responded and talked back to him and he
started this rumor that like I stole
money for a lost you I did this lost big
copyright lawsuit a while ago and Philly
D started this GoFundMe to help fund the
lawsuit and he was saying that I stole
the money and stuff and it was he was
saying that for a long time and it just
really caused a lot of trouble for me
and then I kind of just bust popped the
lid made like a whole thing about him
and from now I just I just really like
making fun of him well and you guys have
had you guys like started a whole like
that whole like sponsorship War too that
was [ __ ] it's not really a war
yeah whatever so uh the last thing on
Mike's uh docket
is um
we I said to your can I can you please
stop calling me a [ __ ] scammer now I
literally never scammed anyone ever bro
yeah I'm telling you dude
I believe that you weren't involved
Logan the my I'm still withholding a
little judgment I I believe that you
believed that he wasn't no no no no no
no trust me The Godfather music
he he is but I capable he is not capable
of of doing that to his community
Through The Voice
we come here we sit down at the table
out of respect to tell the truth of the
matter assistant can we all three do it
yeah mine's awesome
Godfather tell me he had a respect us
your bad mouth off dear friend Logan
Paul I believe me when you say
that you had nothing to do with it we
can do it that's good no that's good see
we're getting something like this and
we're using comedy to get there this is
beautiful but at the same time
so what I'm saying is he's a good kid
and you're gonna let him walk
you're gonna end this thing once and for
all right all right stop I see your
[ __ ] fingers moving but the [ __ ] cut
the [ __ ] [ __ ] move on move on it's
and so I think you know I think I think
me and you can can happily squash the
beef yeah or you want to do the honors
heard that before
thank you but can I ask you a question
is was it intimidating the first time
that you were intimate with Lana
not really uh because
I also don't like fit the build of like
a normal like sexual male either like
it's not like like for example she
wasn't the first porn star that I was
with you know what I'm saying or the
faith you know what I'm saying like so
it wasn't like it wasn't that's and by
the way I hope you know that's not a
brag it sounded like it please it's not
it's it's actually not I have a problem
but that that may yeah so so it was not
a problem like that I'm not like I'm
like a sex act but like I just I just
wish I could do a better job with like
we're not doing a therapy does that mean
you know where the clitoris is or no I
still don't know
all right go ahead yes sorry it's a
little it's a little goofy you gotta go
Charlie M you gotta kind of put it in
the middle Charlie [ __ ] um yeah so so
is that why you guys got the vice
because the casino
honestly
yeah sure
I like the casino reference
next time it's your head you understand
nice beautiful out of one squashed beef
I'm happy I'm happy
thank you Mike can I ask you a question
uh originally you reached out and you
said hey the three of us want to come on
yeah they hadn't even confirmed yet I
just really out there because I was like
whoa this is this is really well I know
they would get a kick out of it they'd
want to do it that's cool yeah I
appreciate you all coming here actually
same happy here yeah we were excited to
come down yeah I was excited to have you
guys down here happy to squash that's my
first time actually meeting all you guys
yeah you're taller in person than I
thought you guys are [ __ ] Giants dude
well that's that's like a known thing
you know but I get that every time I run
into I didn't know you guys were that
tall what are you six five six four no
you're not six four three six six three
this one Zach's been lying about his
height for [ __ ] I'm six two
he's been saying he's 6'4 no no no no no
no I said I want Valerie you're already
tall bro I said I'm six three I'm much
taller really yeah he's a man he's a man
wow do means and also like there is one
more like little beef like a side beef
me and Zach dude had like it wasn't all
me and you dude like Zach instigated a
lot of the beef and actually I'm glad
you brought that up because we we want
to do a ceremonial uh [ __ ] uh can you
grab the the ceremonial items please and
what we want is an i an exchange item
between the two of you to represent I
thought we did that with the bracelets
yeah the bracelets is one aspect but you
you guys specifically have a special
thing and so yeah bring on the the show
in honor of
of our newfound friendship Zach has in
his possession
two pairs of spoiled gym shorts story
behind this what did Mike actually no I
I have to ask is where did this story
come from because because you have to
understand because of your foot aren't
soldiers yeah
these stories grow wings like I'm
halfway surprised I'm halfway surprised
that there's not like a dink toink s
cartoon about me [ __ ] my pants but
Zach here you can use my mic um and now
that I said that there probably will be
on this case by the way on this case I
can say I had nothing to do with it it
was all Zach
uh well first off I just want to say
you're you're a [ __ ] homie dude I'm
sorry for what I said you're [ __ ]
real G and like a cool [ __ ] dude but
uh but yeah hold up the shitty gym
shorts just so that people can see it so
that says his exact same well show this
[ __ ] stain yeah and then Mike if you
could flip that around for me [ __ ] Stan
so Brothers Brothers in Arms or brothers
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] oh you guys should
exchange him like uh basketball players
at the end of the game
so have you ever [ __ ] your pants ever
because you do talk about it a lot yes
but not at the gym which is what it I
did I have so that's why I was like
slightly curious as to where it started
from so there's this uh situation uh
where I was at my sister's wedding yeah
uh my little sister's wet are you are
you cool with this store conversation
it's pretty grotesque oh do your thing
so is that my sister
what do you think they we can't discuss
[ __ ] in front of her I don't know it's
just it's my traditions no so is that my
little sister's wedding in DC she has do
you want to apologize for checking no no
okay she has this she has this wedding
she has this wedding and I have to give
the the uh speech for some reason I gave
her speech like I guess my sister didn't
want to do it she was nervous some [ __ ]
right but I you know have this anxiety
and stress and the night before I was
out networking like I like to do and I
went and I had a gas station Cubano
sandwich oh I don't get you man in
Washington DC not advisable right so you
know I I'm about to give this speech and
I start feeling these like gurgles in my
stomach right and I go and I give the
speech and everything goes fine right
and I'm in this tuxedo everything goes
fine I crush it but my stomach continues
to gurgle right and at some point I go
downstairs into the little bathroom
there it's just a one stalled reception
hall bathroom and I I'm pretty sure I
just the toilet actually fell apart
under the weight of a Hiroshima style
[ __ ] situation been there but I
thought I had
gotten through it right so I put my
pants back on I do like a little water
on the toilet paper like you do at the
sink and you come back into the stall
and handle it right so that night we go
out and we go to the W which sits above
the Capitol building in DC it's this
really nice picturesque place we're
gonna have the the after party there I
go into the bathroom and I'm standing at
the urinal for one second and as I'm
peeing I squeeze out a quick fart oh no
dude
today
thank you thank you so in essence you're
not wrong right but it didn't happen at
the gym so in your defense you started
the rumor before he ever even admit to
[ __ ] correct the story and then well
when you said oh I accept myself then we
it's that kind of party because he's
like oh well now now we have to where'd
you get the sound bite from dude I watch
you like a hawk man it was on policy
yeah dude I that's my job is to watch
everything and when people say dumb [ __ ]
you know but uh I'm a fellow [ __ ]
like have accident I've [ __ ] on lawns
before uh bro our audience knows his ex
claim to fame is that he pulled over and
[ __ ] on someone's grast and then just
left it there like front lawn yeah front
lawn what had you white I had a towel in
my car thankfully but I had to go home I
was on my way to school at the time and
uh yeah it was [ __ ] all over my car seat
it was [ __ ] awful and like a serial
killer he returned to the scene of the
crown time the next day I have a pic I
can show you later if you want to see it
went back the next day it was all
deflated dude
look it like molded in there
it's a dog or something go ahead oh dude
no well now I have these bro this was
really nice yeah I appreciate it and I
we're brother and [ __ ] thank you bro we
should [ __ ] our pants together sometime
okay cool thank you yeah of course okay
hugs wow this is this is a special day
this is this is a special day doing it
also just so you know I'm no longer
allowed at Men's Warehouse what
what'd you do because it was a mental
tuxedo oh [ __ ] you were doing [ __ ] yeah
I had to give it back
no I like did my best but I don't think
why don't you just keep it be like I
can't I can because I wasn't um I wasn't
doing content yet so still making love
sack money and like to buy a random [ __ ]
what's that that was the company I
worked for before I became a What's Love
Sack see less Creator oh it's a make
they make giant uh bean bag okay I'm
still your contact in my phone everybody
still has me damn you return to shitty
tucks that's awesome it was like like it
was like residue like you know damn do
you feel really bad for everyone in your
audience which by the way is probably
one of the more creative and intelligent
audiences on the internet Mike did you
get any brown on your thumb from the the
shorts
does any like residue on your hand like
my fingers feel a little bit more oily
than usual yeah I got a little brown on
there dude we can have a thumb rest oh
you guys want to see the picture of
Zach's [ __ ] I mean I could pull it up
I think you're a gun in for your yeah
I'm ready I just want to get it over
with them all about just powering
through it you know it's like the ninth
inning right now how bad can it be I
don't know what this is this just got
passed to me
I don't know if this is something you're
interested in
um
but
this is I think my dunks today oh that's
who's [ __ ] your pants that's
inappropriate I'm sorry wait actually
did you guys have that graphically yeah
I don't know right when you said it how
is that and they're even the same orange
shorts
like you said we have we have an
operation here is the speed is
impressive I just think my doink thank
you well anyway I'm glad that we we now
have I think found an understanding and
I think that's so now we can fight
against radical people on Twitter and I
I think you had some really base takes
on Twitter lately that I really like to
see you know and I think we align a lot
on that which which I appreciate people
that uh
you know are willing to to say and what
in my opinion is the right thing you
know there's a lot of things going on in
the world where I think is like
objectively there's good and there's the
wrong side of [ __ ] it's just really
frustrating because it just feels like
it seems so common sense yeah and having
to even voice it hurts a little bit
because you're like why am I saying
something that everyone should already
understand it that's what I think too
and we're talking about like you know
mass shootings and abortion and stuff
like that but anyway okay Jeff my bestie
official bestie thanks for having me
thanks bro nice to meet you by the way
how tall are you
six one six six two because you guys
seem like the same height no Mike's he's
taller yeah
yeah
um is that it yeah
it's been the crank dude so the obvious
one first off you know is the is the
Frenemies incident yeah which we touched
on a little bit you wanna do you want to
unpack that more uh there weren't any
Revelations I've had recently new
memories came uh actually yeah there was
I looked up everything because I was
like I gotta [ __ ] debunk this you
know I was in a parade that day I don't
know I'm not I don't know what this has
to do with anything go ahead no I just
put on the videos you're at a parade I
was that I had yeah because you guys are
asking me about the day like what
happened and I I was just like I don't
[ __ ] know yeah three years ago you
know I went to a party with a bunch of
guys I think I was initiated into that
crew a couple of Vlogs before that you
know so oh okay
um but yeah everything still the same I
don't know what you really want to
change about that except you know I was
accused of things that I didn't and
that's why I came on the show that's why
I wanted to come on the show because
absolutely not have I ever
done any of the stuff that you guys were
the main accusation being that you you
provided alcohol yeah for the girls who
were not 21 or and also they were taking
advantage of but obviously first of all
I believe you might have anything by Dom
Yeah by Dom I don't think you had
anything to do with that I don't think
you knew what was going on 100 shots of
us in the Vlog were inserted after
that's what I learned that there were
shots of you guys peeking in the room
even the poor kid out like Alex had
[ __ ] just lived there and then he was
just thrown in like a reaction shot of
like I don't know what he was doing but
oh yeah because it was kind of fun
because everyone cheeking in there look
it just looks so bad horrible yeah like
even though you weren't there like the
the message of it was like whoa yeah
yeah horrible for you guys who don't
know there was
you got I'm sure you guys know about
this situation but uh
when Dom
like
apparently essayed this girl and there
was Clips in that episode of everyone
peeking in the room while they were
intimate and being like yo they're hot
we all what the [ __ ] and so it was like
yeah yeah it was really superimposed in
like they were added in after yeah like
Joe Brick swags have always been kind of
a splice of random got us got it and the
reason I believe he has a vision for how
he wants things to look yeah yeah the
reason I believe you when you say that
is because the end is definitely shot on
a different day my dom is like the girls
said that too I wasn't there for that
but yeah yeah when Dom was like all
sweaty he's like yo I had a threesome or
whatever yeah yeah I never do content
like that I never did I was never into
sexual stuff you know and to get
basically like that's like a me too type
not no actually no it's something
completely different it's an assault and
there's a real victim and for me to be
tied into that you know it hurt it hurt
for a while I mean it still does I'll
still get comments from the the foot uh
soldiers and stuff like that and yeah by
the way that's an ironic reference I
just want even though I saw that even
though I you know I didn't do what they
said I did it still hurts well the pro I
think the problem was that
the article was written and specifically
named you right yeah and so that's kind
of what we were going off of in my
opinion now that some time has passed
and I've got to know you a little bit
more you know I I the thing is I
I do believe you because and to be
honest
there was by their account too there was
already a bunch of alcohol there you
know what I mean yeah there was always
some big bottle that Jack Daniels or
something in Dom's house and I didn't
want to you know at the end of the day
you didn't do anything right so so I
don't think it's your cross to bear like
a ton of guilt or embarrassment or
disassociation forever I think it's
[ __ ] up you know how people hold [ __ ]
over people's heads forever this was a
horrific crime actually that happened
but he didn't do it you know what I mean
and and so I get that that it's been
very painful for you of course I
apologize for all the messages I've sent
you afterwards yeah because I was very
upset about that I mean something like
that's horrible I don't have any I mean
I've been a public figure for a long
time I've never had anybody ever say
that I did something wrong like a woman
say I did something wrong
you know
so yeah that hurt
um but yeah I appreciate you know you
doing this and clearing that up because
it it was something that I felt would
follow me forever no matter what because
there's no way to prove it wrong it's
just he said she said you know I can't
go back even if let's say even if you
did buy the alcohol it's like they made
out of I did right right yeah I believe
you I'm saying even if you did if
there's people out there that say well
he maybe I don't believe him it's like
even if you did buy the alcohol you may
not have known their a or less you
hypothetically you may have known their
age and at the end of the day you know
it was Dom's decision and David's
decision to shoot that video and like
you know it's just you people should be
able to to move on from [ __ ] you know
Dom [ __ ] him right and David [ __ ] yeah
yeah I'm saying him yeah you know
I mean I wouldn't share an ambulance
with him he'd be going by himself
yeah
dumb
there's only one ambulance don't make
one bread okay we're on a serious topic
I appreciate it oh yeah is that it
Swatch the beef you guys no there's more
there's more no there's more like this
one this feels like some major [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro well like you guys are like
yeah of course yeah no I mean that's a
horrible thing to have tied to your name
yep yeah absolutely yeah but I just want
to say like in the report you know they
specifically named you right so I called
that reporter and I I yeah yeah I was
upset about that too yeah you know so
yeah I I went after everybody that was
spreading lies about me and I know you
didn't know me at the time you were
going off of you know
your other counterpart at the time yeah
and whatever you know like I said
everything made me reevaluate my life
and I needed to at the time you know
otherwise I might be in a much darker
place right now so I don't regret
anything yeah
okay that's good and then there's the
thing where like your body came to my
house twice I can't confuse a grown man
I can't control me talk about him you
know you want me to call him in here we
get another F on the road
I have a restraining order
oh yeah he told me to ask you if we
could drop that if we
that's not my problem the first time it
happened someone it showed up on our uh
subreddit somebody posted his he made a
story on Instagram of him driving past
my house at night with the windows open
like my office is facing the street and
like it's a gated community
and he wrote some caption like we know
where you live yeah
we can get to you some [ __ ] like that
and everyone's like yo what the [ __ ]
this is insane uh and then this is your
friend his bestie will you talk [ __ ]
yeah my friend I grew up with yeah sure
you're cool with that no I'm not cool
with that I'm saying
[ __ ] happens like okay I've made
mistakes you know well nothing ever
happened I mean I would get a
restraining order if someone was driving
past my house as well so I guess well I
did actually well I texted Jeff I was
like bro
I gotta call the police
like no offense because we were talking
we were hard job at that time yeah I was
like bro uh
of course yeah yeah what happened again
it happened again like one was during
the day one was during the night and I
was like bro I got I gotta yeah bro he
haunted me too I I'm worried about him
too you know damn but actually it was a
good thing because we tightened our
security
so he just exposed some holes yeah
he got in so [ __ ] easy bro
and yeah so so that happened
um no thank you Cody yeah and this stuff
those holes yeah thanks bro shout out
I'm glad you're overseas though he wants
a consulting rate from you yeah no I'm
glad you're just I'm when he went back
to Miami I was monitoring him he went
back to Miami I could tell in his insta
stories I was like thank God [ __ ] god
he's he's actually he picked up
skydiving and base jumping so uh the
odds are looking good for you you know
face jumping is like one out of ten you
die wait is that the one I don't want to
put out no what'd you say no absolute
said I don't want it you jump off a
building or a cliff and you have one
parachute you don't have the extra one
really that badly it's bad it's just one
yeah really yeah I think like two or
three guys recently just died like Alvin
and these wings too you know those like
squirrels he does that [ __ ] he's 250
pounds that's the Gnar do you slightly
worry about him hiking to the top of the
Hollywood sign and Wing suiting directly
into yeah yeah like worried about
everything through the [ __ ] window
and he's a big [ __ ] guy bro let me
tell you he's trying to get verified on
Instagram and he was like yeah I need
more press because there was press
we were going to a party for The
Chainsmokers and he was like look you
can't be bringing your friends around
him no that he was coming and there
wasn't enough well you were me going
backstage and stuff yes and he I I had
to clear the people that I was with and
all of a sudden six foot nine Cody comes
out in a wingsuit you know like come on
let me come and just go tries to wing
suit into the Uber and I'm like hey Jeff
man like isn't this the same dude that
tried to look where we come from
he grew up on rap music and stuff like
that and you know he's just inspired by
that you know
the streets the street I like rap music
too well you don't live your life like
it he's been in prison multiple times
for a large portion of his life and you
know I always think one day's gonna
learn his lesson from these arrests and
he just doesn't
I mean he's been good lately sober now
yeah and it's a start
um yeah he's got a lot of mental
illnesses and he's he's you know not the
mental
Cody you're you're a good soldier yeah
he's a good soldier man so you're
welcome you got a soul and please I just
want you to know Cody no horse heads
no beef you're a good man just leave me
the [ __ ] alone he did kill himself once
by accident no come on come on that's it
that's it
please
well you got into it you can't say
something and did that affect him
probably yeah he was young at the time
but he was always so big you know he's
like Lenny from Rice yeah exactly
exactly that's exactly what I said just
squeezing dogs Yeah Yeah
by accident he didn't mean to
yeah
according to this
uh point two half up almost half a
percent of base jumpers are injured and
point zero four percent per jump you
don't sub your toe if something goes
wrong no yeah you know if you're injured
I think but that's per jump how do you
get into yeah how do you get injur base
shopping is there a way to It's All or
Nothing yeah like you
yeah oh you kind of just splat
for sure you turn into that dude it's
like you're the beef you're going
through the yeah and then the other
thing is obviously I made a lot of jokes
about your eye that's all good you know
I don't know I I assumed you were a good
supporter but it was mostly I was just
trying to be yeah yeah of course I
thought that if you're gonna dish it you
gotta be able to take it it's all good
it is what it is I was just messing with
Dan too I don't know I'm a [ __ ] it's a
good it's like it's a really good
opportunity for jokes during like it's
just you know
yeah to be honest before that I was like
I'm too good looking to be a comedian so
I need to smash my face or something if
I'm gonna do this I'm just kidding guys
that was a little joke for them it feels
serious it's probably gonna get used
against you in courts yeah good [ __ ] man
[ __ ] I take that back no no
no
that was just deflection I'm deflecting
with my my insecurities you know I got
you we're good guys make all the eye
jokes you want it's fine okay thank you
so that that's I was gonna bring a blind
person in here to just have hanging out
with me like I'm doing like a
Make-a-Wish
but I'm not I'm not blind I also I have
one reason I mean you platform the
Oliver tree which is a problem yeah
perfect dude What's your deal with Ethan
Klein you guys friends no first of all
Ethan Klein is an abomination of the
human race that dude has no notice all
the cuts we had to take out all the
stuff he said yeah that was too real
about family children I was like bro I
can't put I can't hear that he really
has been spazzing lately and especially
with with our current state that we're
in we're trying to squash beef I didn't
even feel comfortable air in this so
you'll see I put a disclaimer after yeah
I saw I noticed that you said
yeah
I appreciated that online okay he's a
domestic terrorist
I didn't know I thought that was funny I
do a little editing I spice it up with
the pictures too that's just that I mean
why would you include that photo I just
thought it was funny like because you're
not actually a domestic terrorist right
so I put you with this wig on just
unsuccessful he was saying it to me he
was saying it hard last week saying
January the whole thing that happened in
January was your part you were part of
it why are you actually
no but I I'm just saying what he said I
did say and I'm just this is what I'm
just saying it I'm not saying like I'm
not like saying it I'm just recapping I
don't know if you saw I said so much NRA
okay and it turned into a whole thing
yeah I think you'd say that yeah yeah
you don't want to say stuff like that
you can I don't think yeah you filmed
that you you filmed it and then put it
on YouTube yeah yeah yeah no it was live
and these guys oh it was live okay it
was Live Well it turned into like Donald
Trump Jr was tweeting about me and [ __ ]
it was a whole thing bro but like but my
joke about that is I go it's not like I
said you're my favorite coin right
what's the fastest I don't want to get
roped into this stuff you are no
laughter massive terrorist now too
that's my joke because obviously I you
know I voted for Joe Biden but I'm it's
not I'm not it's not my interest anyway
I'm against violence of all forms cool
that's it that's it it's not funny
um Dan do you have any shorts or
something for me you know maybe oh did
you make me any gifts or anything like a
funny give them on your eyes to show
yourself ah yeah I want a [ __ ] eye I
want one of your eyes Dan give him your
good eye
you know yeah he put that arm out I'm
like oh damn all right he thought your
name was AB but because he thought he
had beef with somebody that had some
tick tocks about him or something yeah
no he he looked I don't have a tick tock
Jeff for boys I don't know yeah we're
tight I think I was just not trying to
throw you under the bus if anything that
was a compliment because I was saying
you're like a young guy cool looking
like you would be a tick tocker you know
yeah no if I'm calling your appearance a
tick tock or it's a compliment maybe I
misunderstood them maybe it was a
misinterpretation but we're good we're
good I mean that's oh so did you get
your own did you get oh sorry should I
tip with that in my pocket yeah
I'm just really excited to move past
this beef because there's so many
meaningful conversations we could be
having that just you know this feels
like oh go Lord uh can you maybe put it
down for one second grab it after
you want a glove
you're just gonna you're gonna yeah
what's that place called Raw
you're looking for a nice one yeah yeah
how's that feel
s
once you've seen fatty yeah there you go
oh no just put it right in the middle
yep you just put it in the middle there
you go yeah squeeze that in there
yeah
oh yeah yeah squeeze it
there we go that feels good wow that is
one squashed beef my friend
Captain America or some [ __ ] you guys
all have salmonella now we will save the
Earth is that what we do after yes yeah
so so okay good I feel like lighter you
know what I'm saying like a like a like
a
piece of meat has been lifted off my
about the uh yeah a couple of ounces
yeah it feels good yeah but you know I'm
happy to see this you know I think this
was really necessary this was important
and you know he feels lighter and I'm
happy we can you know have fun in the
future I think so and you know I'm the
truth is I always liked you three people
I did I know it's crazy to say and
that's why I was like always like I
liked you too before you had accused of
being a horrible piece of [ __ ] yeah I'm
a domestic terrorist that's worse
yeah
um I guess it's just like I guess it's
just like a a reason to like give people
more time to like build out like who
they actually are you know what I'm
saying as opposed like it's good to sit
with people and find out who they
actually are instead of like this isn't
you but this is like everybody on the
internet instead of like basing your
entire opinion of someone on 10 second
Clips 30 seconds like yeah I think I'm
trying to
lead out with a softer touch you know
what I mean that's awesome it's nice I
love that for you we need more of that
Ethan too like like being completely
honest we just need more of that in the
[ __ ] world dude the world is becoming
[ __ ] really cold and heartless and
just like it in a way it always has been
but I just feel like we continue to move
more and more in that direction I think
people need to be better to each other
dude like I think I think like just that
single like tenant is probably the one
that we're missing the most of which is
just like yo respect and be good to your
to other people bro
it's not really that hard of a [ __ ]
notion dude yeah you know what um
you know how like these these like
reclusives have like a list of bullies
that they're gonna sell when they're
older so I'm crossing your guys's name
off oh yeah remember the scene in uh in
uh
uh Billy Madison yeah yeah yeah or sorry
and Billy Madison my bad where he's like
he's putting the lipstick on and he
crosses them off the list dude yeah so
I've got ninja off the list and this is
this is beautiful you know and and I
don't know is there anything else you
guys want to talk about I mean now it's
the Open Stage as friends that we could
share our in our most you know fears
thoughts desires are you happy
I actually am yeah
nice me too at the moment I'm very happy
I'm happy to hear that because you know
I I knew you were struggling a lot so
yeah it's really nice to hear that that
you're in a good place hey I need all
the friends I could get you know
yeah I feel like I'll be here every day
9 A.M
come on by just Sprint don't bring Cody
I got even verified on Instagram but you
know um
yeah happiness is kind of a it's kind of
like an illusion it's more about like
contentness right yeah so that's that's
how I feel I feel content you know so
this is working time it's actually
working making peace makes it feel
better it does okay and do all for that
[ __ ] and you guys are good guys you know
what I'm saying thank you I just I'm
just excited now that we could like do
shows and talk about other [ __ ] like not
have to now that we like bet and by the
way this like kind of drained me I'm
kind of drained now after it but it
would be nice to sit and talk about
topics
I think political whatever we want to
talk about now we can talk about you
know we don't have to worry about like
oh one time he said she's a Twinkie like
one time like he called him a scammer we
got to put it to bed yeah it's like oh
yeah I agree I never thought we'd be at
a point where we could podcast about
some random [ __ ] I mean you I guess like
that you would ever be down so I mean
they're the future yes right so I had I
invited you on the show and you seem
interested yeah but then uh I guess you
said I was scary which I get and then
you basically
responding but again it was via Twitter
DMS which I never checked like I don't I
don't even know if I like saw your
response however I felt like this was an
important first I didn't want our entire
first episode to just be about all of
the sweet lovely things you said about
me over the years yeah yeah so I mean
now it would be you know better okay
yeah yeah yeah
I feel good I think I said a total of
four words on this podcast anyway so
we'll have to do one in the future
um we can splice in from other from like
your podcasts oh I'm sure make it seem
like you're more yeah I'm here I'm here
it was great I think this was it was a
beautiful thing to witness yeah actually
actually you know what I want to say
during the Frenemies thing
my name came up a lot and conversations
you were having on camera
and you all and it's kind of impressive
on you always refrained from saying
anything bad about me like I forget what
podcast it was but they brought my name
up and you it was it was her podcast oh
is your pocket oh when when Trisha was
on Career podcast oh oh yeah to be
honest yeah I was like damn that's
that's honestly really cool you're in
that category of people that I would
rather just allow to [ __ ] on me than
start the war because I feel like if you
and I were to go to war you would find
everything awful I've ever done what you
do Ethan well no it's just you know
you're a researcher and I'm good what
were we saying about him you're good at
it for sure but I just you're like yeah
you're the type that could unearth a new
Scandal for me and I was walking on a
thin line for a while oh yeah internet
please or like interviews yeah for the
Internet
it's like the Interpol yeah well the
interpol's a thing but he's got it's I
think it's a testament also to your
squad bro you just have a [ __ ] ass no
we have a good quality infrastructure I
say you got a picture of the ace family
autographed in the bathroom oh my God
that's we got that in person uh yeah
it's fine well yeah yeah we were at Ace
Fest and I'll tell you you went to Ace
Fast and I'll tell you
we had a good time we had a hell of a
good time that's what we said we said
yeah so this is turning the leaf right
we went there and Austin might be BFF
material no really yeah because we went
there all right well don't just start
giving it yeah
you just started doing this with
everyone no no well okay
Maybe
we're good recurring don't risk your
recurring guests for some random friend
like faux friendship like bro we do this
[ __ ] all the time right like you could
hit us up you're like oh I need a little
I need some [ __ ] energy today you
call me I need some SOB stories you call
Jeff I need [ __ ] Tana to bring some
[ __ ] sassiness you call Tana you know
what I'm saying like now you got us
locked in you know yeah but you might
need some you might need Austin McBroom
to come Flex on you or something you
know and then when I pull up in his
Lamborghini but he won't he won't call
he'll come one time he won't come back
we're workers awesome you know what I'm
saying that's a good point Jeff calls me
says he'll come on the show I want to
talk about Andrew date today I go I talk
about Andrew T you know what I'm saying
what's your thoughts on Andrew taint I'm
sick of them I don't I mean I never
really liked him you know I like what
his son Hassan did that was cool oh yeah
that was great yeah I'm not a fan would
it make you happy I'm gonna ask you this
question because because listen
keep not to keep going back to it but he
is my best friend and I believe that
you've given him a you haven't given
them a proper Shake of the feather would
you be willing to
be a little bit more
understanding and more friendly towards
Logan if you knocked Andrew Tate Out ooh
yeah dude is that on the table
I'll tell you what man yes what if he
takes down total absolutions question
yeah do the ticket sell
yeah yeah hell yeah yeah and dude like
so so like you that's actually
interesting because Tate's you know he's
a fighter that's right four-time kickbox
where in Romania uh yeah in a basement
kickboxing League's made out of plastic
the only thing he's like the videos are
out the only thing he's a champion of is
human trafficking dude does he relate
traffic he bro he fought a bunch of bums
and yes he does now well hold on I'm
gonna do Devil's Advocate even though me
and you aren't probably that far off on
this topic but like from a [ __ ]
rotate up what he says is that he that
that he was absolutely he's also said
that I pay I moved to Romania he
literally said I moved to Romania
because the the rape laws are like cool
here I did see that and and he said and
he says I like living in Romania because
I pay off all the costs and nobody will
[ __ ] with me so why the [ __ ] am I
supposed to believe him that he just got
off because it was a misunderstanding so
what he did professionally before he was
like a multi-level marketing scammer was
that he uh
you don't like the way I talk about it
no sorry no I don't know why because I'm
going in right no no go go go go I just
I hope you get clipped out in those tick
tocks by Andrew Tate's Fanboys there's
so many other people we started ending
up dude they're so wild but he had a
like a whole Farm of web webcam girls
correct like in his basement a farm
literally oh he was growing yeah and
like and then and then what's
interesting is
um the U.S embassy reported that he was
keeping people against their will
captive
and his compound his sex slavery
compound right and so that's why the
Romanian police went in there and
rescued some girls who were missing and
he was literally keep [ __ ] human
trafficking them into forcing them to do
webcam stuff for him the man's a [ __ ]
like next level mobster criminal did you
like what Hassan did you like yeah
Hassan did a great job did a great job
I'm gonna be honest I didn't watch the
whole thing with with porno the thing so
I'm being a little light on it today
because we're talking about this on the
podcast that we have coming out soon and
it's kind of the start of all of it but
does this to me all the time he saves
the good stuff well as I should have
talked about it no no we haven't it's
it's but but anyways what I was getting
at was
um
the pendulum of
societal kind of thoughts on stuff
swings back and forth and as you know
over the past several years it's been
swinging a lot towards world and towards
liberalism and pregnant men and whatever
other things that are are actually
disagree it's been swinging to the right
I mean these are ideas currently it's
starting to swing back now it's been
dude really you think so yes it's not
not as far as internet's concerned I
think the internet the woke [ __ ] is like
cosmetic bro the real [ __ ] is like
having literal Theo like fascist
Christians on the Supreme Court yeah I'm
[ __ ] repealing uh abortion rights for
women you know like literally people
feeling comfortable enough like Ben
Shapiro and Crowder to go online and
just be like [ __ ] trans people like just
saying outright like no I'm saying I
think the the pendulum is right now like
far right in my opinion
I believe that it's swinging back that
way and I think Tick Tock is helping
with that a lot I think Tick Tock is a
massive [ __ ] contributor and that's
why I think Tate's I think that's why
Tate's doing so well right now because I
think it's moving back into that
direction yeah it's kind of crazy that
people actually believe like here's one
I think people just haven't seen
anything like it before and they'll be
sick of it in a month I I don't see him
though I think I feel that but let's
listen to this I mean I have no reason
to believe anything this man says
probably 14 of the reason I moved to
Romania because in Eastern Europe none
of this garbage flies if you don't know
the police and say he raped me back in
1988 because we should have done
something by the band remember the
police say right in yesterday say okay
if you've got physical evidence or is
there ccdb proof where to happen Okay
let's go interview him right now and if
it wasn't really reality oh we went to
the club we got drunk she agreed to go
back to my house we start having sex and
then we carried on having sex and then
we have sex and she didn't say anything
wrong and then she texts me afterwards
and I didn't text back and now she's
saying I raped her the police would be
like okay she's an idiot bye no not in
the West in the west you can tell them
that exact story you're still [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] in the west when people
say why didn't Romania and I explain my
five reasons one of them is the metoo
era think oh well you're a rapist I say
no I'm a [ __ ] rapist but I like the
idea of being able to just say to do
what I want
is
incredible
like apparently it's he's been accused
of rape enough times he had to remove he
had to move to Romania to avoid did you
see
yeah dude it's so disturbing bro wait
was that one was that one fake was that
one fake fake what do you mean where he
he's beating the [ __ ] out yeah but he
said that that was an act like he's
lying
of course he's lying he said it was like
some s m type like [ __ ] what kind of s m
where you beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] isn't
that like bondage and stuff like he
[ __ ] and punched her in the face hard
dude and she looks scared her shoes
scared I mean but that's what I'm that's
what I'm at that's the question I'm
asking like there's some nasty [ __ ] that
goes in on in the sex world
where that's like I guess uh the girl
hasn't said anything to me but all it is
is a clip of him like beating the [ __ ]
out of a woman and then he came and said
by the way by the way I'm scared you
know you probably know this is what I do
I just I just I if you don't have
someone that brings out the other angle
whether or not I give a [ __ ] about what
it is you're a tater tot
or you just uh chat with random people
and I was just challenging kids that I
asked them what they thought on Tate and
anybody who said they liked him I just
said I was gonna [ __ ] him up and just
see how mad they get and they're like
he's a kickboxing world champion
[ __ ] that's awesome I was just
trolling but it was funny to see the
reactions of these kids they how old are
they the people that like him
college kids oh my God even that old
that I thought it was because technology
10 to 18. is the main demo so I've been
attributing a lot of the success to that
demo that's crazy what are you gonna say
you were about to defend Andrew no I was
not dude not no I wasn't I just said
that to to the point that
bringing up the point he was making is
that sometimes people do have
relationships where there is a level of
yeah but very physical sexual I don't
know bro did you see that video yeah
sure I mean I've seen it do you want to
see it yeah you know I mean there's no
context right right but like do people
that like like in movies the man the man
moved to Romania so he could rape women
so I'm just saying somebody said by the
way I'm really not defended I dude I'm
with you no I get it I get it I get it I
get it I just present the opposing view
I get it because otherwise it turns into
Ethan it turns into a railroad
you know listen
I just think this man doesn't get
deserve much of a benefit of the doubt
when he says in England or Germany or
America or any of the western world
right now you've decided to live in a
country where any woman any ex any
[ __ ] [ __ ] who works at Greg's who
you bought pasty from at some point in
the future can destroy your life this me
too era [ __ ] has nothing right now
yeah shout out I don't think he I don't
think he would take the fight with Logan
I think what happens I mean dude the
thing is that's gonna be a lot of money
on the table yeah dude and it's a cool
fight for Logan I think it sells tickets
and and it ended that would be and it
gives him the ability and it gives Logan
the chance to beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody that a lot of people don't like
yeah I would I would watch that fight
that'd be nice I think anybody would
watch that yeah I mean as long as it
gets done soon because to your point I
mean Logan says the same thing he
doesn't know how long he's gonna be
around for fair yeah I don't know he's
yeah he's gonna fall off soon
um yeah it was entertaining I did go
through like one night of binging and
then you don't have a choice it just
shows up on your feet yeah but yeah I
was sick of it it is entertaining right
yeah but it's like it's entertainment
right well and the one thing you have to
give to him is clearly he knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing as it pertains to
marketing himself
you have to you have to I mean with the
affiliate link and taking his content
not having a profile and just having
people share it with Tick Tock nowadays
and how the algorithm works it clicked
some people just find the right moment
they don't have to be a genius it's just
the right moment in time right place the
right time and something works I don't
think it's a genius thing it's a pyramid
scheme it's been done pretty incredible
I mean like it's incredible
and like it feels like just a couple
months he went from like relative of
security to everything like insane
[ __ ] notoriety pretty incredible
stuff if he can I mean as long as he can
capitalize fast on he can make good it
is
make a lot of money we need Logan to
come through how does it feel
um when did you start only fans how long
ago was that
um I started like a year and a half ago
it's has it been like a big bit like
blessing for your life in terms of I
don't know everything
um
blessing is an interesting word it's fun
you like it it's all I mean it's all
positive for you is it all positive yeah
yeah it's cool you should start one okay
that's what that's what Trisha kept
telling me you would actually make money
you'd make a lot of money honestly it'd
be keemstar and uh that's what I'm
thinking honestly what about you and Kim
started to squash all the beef just just
do some talking in the shower yeah
that's what I was thinking about why
don't you start the only fans Jeff it's
not all about the money for me Ethan I
don't know what it is for me
um that accusation because I'm Jewish
entering a different line of work that
no I I don't feel any need to okay you
know
more power to you Tana I think I think
but I'm gonna get him on that I love it
he's gonna be on my own sneak totally
against his will
um on some Andrew Tate [ __ ] it's gonna
be in my basement oh yeah but you know
speak one thing that I really think is
great about only fans in that whole
industry is what you're touching on the
porn industry is so [ __ ] and all these
these these these like these psychos for
the longest time were making money off
everyone else's work now these girls are
becoming self-made millionaires rich and
Rich and Rich doing good all on their
own terms it's awesome Yep into the
talent yeah for sure I've always had a
lot of respect for women sex workers
strippers anything I don't give a [ __ ]
cause look at what I did I saw weed I I
was a hustler I sold drugs you know now
if Tana came to me to collect money
and I would give her the money but I'm
saying other people may not take her as
serious and you know I'm just saying I
respect it and I just haven't really
thought about it but maybe I will now
maybe I'll think about it I'm telling
you bro I would love to see it there was
one dude who got I had I had that why
wouldn't you ever with the way that you
are with your your
hair
there's got to be something you know
what if it was a naked burger review
whatever I just I don't know I don't
know why I haven't I just
it just never really spoke to me because
I feel like a lot of that stuff is like
Moment In Time whereas my like long-term
play is go to go like speak at a school
and talk to these kids about how to like
get their their heads in check how to
not do like like real stuff I'm not
saying you can't do both I'm not saying
that but I just feel like there's like
an inherent so like Adam 22 straddles
right and I had the opportunity to go
out there and do only fans I had the
number one retired porn star in the
world who happily I'm sure would have
started a new Channel with me we could
have made millions and millions but
there was just something about it that
always was like
for me personally as a like what I with
what I do like once I cross that line I
can't come back like once I yeah once
you're fixed on the internet
like I definitely don't what am I doing
I think somebody's gonna pay to see me
pull my phone who is it is it like no
one wants to see that they would I'd
have to pay them no that's what I'm
trying to say but you know uh this one
guy I know hell of people like taika for
example
dude but not right away that's so crazy
no but Tyga's got like the vibe of like
he's Tyga like dude like I'm a [ __ ]
37 year old X crackle
yeah and like dude like what am I gonna
do like today I'm gonna show you my dick
and talk about Lexapro
you know there was a dude uh he was on a
reality show what's his [ __ ] name
but he went to only fans apparently he's
one of the biggest guys on there do you
think about Harry Josie yeah Harry oh
dude he's crushing it on only thing dude
he's like the first biggest
he's like in the top 10. but it's the
same situation with him like he's a
[ __ ] good looking six foot like 12
[ __ ] dude's got washboard stomach he
works out and that's seven feet by the
way yeah you're right yeah like I said
this took a lot out of me but uh but
yeah
now you're dependent that's how Rogan
does it no do you think that really
affected you
it's not affecting me now like I'm not
actually coming down
no I think it really does get me into a
literature it's vitamins it's just
vitamins yeah
okay well you told me it's a cumulative
effect like I needed well I think in
theory it is I don't believe it does
anything though I haven't tried it oh
you had a I don't know if you want to
talk about this because oh my God just
let me go oh you want to go no I'm just
kidding I was like okay I'm not hey I'm
not Andrew Tate I'm not keeping you guys
you're working with you what did I have
any time what would you talk about
apparently you had a stalker an only fan
stalker oh he said princess here I was
confused that you're pregnant I was
actually rocking it was like a dartboard
I figured maybe it would hit and you
would just start spilling your guts
right no I was actually I feel like
everything has happened to me online I
was like I had a pregnancy scan
um yeah I still do I have a stalker
right now for my only fans
I don't I mean I've had a couple
stalkers in life but this one's for my
only fans and it was weird it just
started as a lot of messages and then he
started showing up to my house and just
giving cold knocking did you yeah but I
have security so they would like send
him away and then sending all these
flowers here I am thinking it's like
some guy some secret admirer it's just
him he lives in a van he spent a lot of
money on my only fans
bless his heart I know he's a good
customer I think he's trying to kill me
I think the fact that you have you have
security is is good I there's a lot of a
lot of people show up to my house yeah
yeah in your line of work
nobody's right it nasties people [ __ ]
crazy day one it's been even since far
before only fans just through YouTube
and you know I know is it mostly dudes
the weird dudes or is there is there
like yeah I think it's always been like
weird guys I don't think I've ever had a
girl stalker that'd be fun out there the
the job is available it is it is yeah
but you you had some stalkers I've had I
want to say stalkers but I've definitely
had people show up to my house I've been
swatted a bunch of times the FBI came in
I've been spotted like twice Cody
yeah yeah people show up at my house I
live in a building I have a door man but
they still figure it out that's good you
you're on the street well I used to live
at Logan's and when I was dating Lana
that was when it was the worst like
people would show up and they would they
would like us had security probably yeah
but they would hit the doorbell
sometimes or like or on the outside of
the gate and they would be like I'm the
Antichrist send Lana out and like they
were throwing like oh it was some real
[ __ ] up and then like once me and her
broke up there's nothing because once
again I have to say like no one cares
about a 37 year old excracket like
they're not gonna knock it at my door
like yo man let me see those man boobs
like no one gives a [ __ ] Bro useless I
need to write another book in a hurry
check out the fifth vital on Amazon it
is a great it's a good book someone here
read it in that I read it I read it yeah
Cameron liked it it's a slack did you
like it I I gotta say within the past 10
years it's my all-time favorite memory
nice thank you I didn't want to get too
serious but it's uh very meaningful wow
that's quite an endorsement it took me a
long time to write it bro years and
years and years
it's been really effective sold hundreds
of thousands of copies I hope it's those
hundreds of thousands more
yeah so um in short I think I just do
maybe I'll just show my [ __ ] and like
full outfit
just my dick out thoughts yeah you mean
right now our only fans on only fans I
would subscribe
as long as Gila gets 100 of the money
yeah she's my she's my pimp
I didn't know if she was gonna be here
today I kind of thought maybe she would
join
yeah I don't like she you know what I
mean
she she likes to avoid this kind of [ __ ]
that I I get her in you know what I mean
she she doesn't want to see it on her
face but she was like yeah everybody
yeah it's funny because like I always
would see it and I would like see you
just like right when you just start to
go into something like you would just
see her just automatically yeah oh no
not again yeah yeah yeah there was a
time when it was like every week I was
getting into trouble just a [ __ ] huge
like pseudo cancellation on Twitter
cancellation you know so it's so
exhausting man yeah I mean but I've been
good lately well I did say but I'm not
seriously well yeah yeah there's maybe
been a few incidents there's been a few
but the good thing last week some
doozies yeah the good thing about the
the
champ which is I'm just referencing it
yeah not saying it can you even say it
in air quotes as a reference
what bleep it
just believe the b word yeah
terrorists but the good thing about that
was that my fans weren't actually mad at
me and that's when it you know sucks the
most is when your own fans are angry at
me yeah like yo you can't say because
they want you to behave because they
know that if you don't
they could lose you and and defend them
like for example what do you think about
Steve
Steve will do it I don't know anything
about why he was banned gone permaban
channels I don't know really no I saw
this two days ago his Channel's gone you
know why yeah I don't know anything
about it you know dude listen I I know
Steve Steve's a sweet kid he does do a
lot of stuff for for people he does a
lot of you know charitable stuff for
people
um you know I think he I think my guess
is that he does tiptoe around some some
topics that he's wild yeah there's no
question by the way not in no way I'm
saying he I don't know the circumstance
I don't know if it was yeah I don't know
whatever but priority was just on like a
strike five type like it was just like
he's had a lot of strikes yeah whatever
the finals
go out with with six nine and they went
to the favelas in Brazil and were giving
out money to what seemed like I don't
even know who these people were but like
you know there was guns in the video
yeah and like not like handguns like
that's pretty yeah so I would assume
that might have been a part of it but I
don't know I'll say it right now yeah
I'll say
I'll say sometimes I get in trouble with
YouTube and I'm just like this is so
[ __ ] dumb so I don't know what he did
you know he's Steve's a good Steve is a
good kid I know I know I don't like
their steak and uh association with
steak oh we were gonna get you sponsored
I wish I'd be a [ __ ] everybody
sponsor everybody's sponsored by steak
now though yeah
is there a crypto gambling scene based
in Kurosawa but I think what you're
going to see is you're going to see a
lot of those things that you're bringing
up start to fall off and eventually
you're gonna eventually you're gonna
have to say the old stake was X Y and Z
because eventually they're gonna get so
big well I think the FBI is probably
taking a close look at Steak right now
so we'll see what happens yeah but
they'll probably make the changes that
are necessary to make
yeah yeah I don't know I'm not against
gambling or anything the whole thing is
Shady I remember the whole I remember it
dude think about it bro I was on the
house who do you think the first call
went to after Aiden did the [ __ ] show
you know what I'm saying like you guys
are that close bro I was in Spain and I
get a call at six in the morning like yo
we got a problem
Aiden went wrong and thought he could
take down nobody cared nobody even cared
about it and he's still gambling so it
doesn't matter deals got bigger so yeah
that's all happens
um HD3 no I'm not gonna get into this
now
but uh anyway what a nice time huh yeah
yeah I'm happy we did it and I mean what
I said earlier you know your audience
let me tell you
when I needed them the most they came
and supported me and your empathy
when I needed it it meant a lot you may
have saved me in a way you know and we
thought we were coming in here to fight
it out but no
no not today no no not today
there we go today we're washing the beef
you know and emotionally healing yeah I
just want to throw this out there after
um the whole ding-dong thing happened I
just I was in a dark place and um don't
mock my trauma I'm not I'm being dead
serious and if and honestly like he's
kind of mocking your child no I'm not
yeah
dude and like after I lost that deal bro
and
if it honestly wasn't for you guys and
more so the audience dude I I don't
think I would uh you're trying to win
over our audience yeah I don't think no
but he's right our audience they they
could they are they can really he told
me I'm like I don't think you understand
I was flung off a crane had my brain
bashed in and then exiled by a group
that were all my friends not uh some of
them you know didn't
um
so yeah it meant a lot that you
understand the situation you know yeah I
always had a lot of empathy for you you
know in the whole situation by the way
yeah how do you feel about David kind of
his career is kind of sideways Now isn't
it oh I feel real bad for him yeah yeah
yeah yeah what do you want me to say to
that I don't know
do you have any shot in freuda what's
that mean it's like pleasure and
another's misfortune
no I don't give a [ __ ] I mean
I'm gonna be honest I watched the
favorite episode of you reacting to that
podcast they put out
I watched it this morning just to you
know because I try not to think about it
I try not to talk about it too much
because it does [ __ ] my head up you know
yeah yeah but just to refresh everything
I watched it today and it was dope how
you saw what I'm trying to say because a
lot of times I can't even articulate
what I'm trying to say and you got it so
yeah thank you we're dogs bro we're BFFs
my close second
Hannah you're not what you weren't in
consideration but I'm just [ __ ] here
I think I think today I was just [ __ ]
yeah
I'm so glad I'm so happy you came no I
am I and you know what I'm happy to be
my apologies to you or or because you
didn't you know you did nothing to me
I'm just an innocent person you really
didn't even talk about any of the stuff
that like we did which is great
you know what I'm saying but like I
thought I guess we talked about you
you're like you want to talk about
something no but like there we had back
and forth and there was only the back I
feel bad I thought maybe you would you
want to apologize I mean yeah I mean I
think we all go ahead you know well
yeah make me look like the [ __ ] well
you know I dude the other side went on
some podcasts and said some things that
were not you know great actually what I
called you was a bully remember that
remember I called you bully yeah yeah
it's fine
it's really not even like that it's not
that bad yeah and I get it I felt
bullied at the time yeah do I should I
say sorry for that no you know it just
feels like that like I didn't say
anything else besides that that was like
the only thing I said yeah yeah and it
was after you mentioned a 20 yard well
once again no it's too big the wall to
wall in this room yeah how would you
even very enough blood to facilitate a
boner in that situation a pool anyways
can we get an image of that cam
uh this is um this is breaking uh this
is who is this guy in the photo with
wait who is that
you want to break this down for me oh
that wasn't reference
wait what is oh it's just an image yeah
is that the only Fan's font yeah wow I'm
never gonna live I'm never gonna live
this down bro hold on like honestly out
of all the things once again like I
literally you got abs in that photo yeah
I was like no I know but I I was I was
really flexing them really like I was
doing everything even then you can see
them is pretty impressive you have a
massive scar yeah I have a lot of scars
wait what's this from uh splenectomy I
have my spleen removed oh [ __ ] yeah
that's a rough one eh
read the fifth spiral dude it's in there
it's a whole chicken the whole story
about it yeah did you guys buy this
point this boat with dink dunk or what
oh bro we would have to pay then bro
and I'm just kidding but now we're now
it's friendly ribbon yeah yeah I think
it even was before too like it's just
dude like I still want that deal back
that I lost
like imagine the calls are like hey we
heard about dink doink like I'm like
what are you saying right now what is
that really what the [ __ ] that's pretty
interesting
well I'd love to have you maybe we can
do a friend episode soon where it's like
the beef is squashed just talk now let's
start new beef yeah new beef with other
people yeah of course always down yeah
Dirty Laundry baby
pays the rent and I got a big mortgage
now all right who should we take on that
big I mean it's who haven't you taken on
yet fresh beef yeah who have you just
never talked [ __ ] about oh my God that's
a great question that would take some re
I'd have to really sit down and think
about it bro You've Won it every single
day there's no one
trying to think of my body like who are
my friends why don't you go after your
friend have you gone after Biden or
Pelosi or anybody oh yeah I [ __ ] hate
both of them we shouldn't bite in all
this all the time on the show he's too
[ __ ] old dude I'm like so tired of
the Jerry the Jerry autocracy old people
running our country I wish they would
[ __ ] die yeah all right for sure it's
it's not I'm not gonna kill him I'm just
waiting can I wish death on somebody I
mean no no I can't explicitly you can't
do this okay wait can I say I wish he
dies
I mean I do it's funny
I do it's fun but I'm just saying like
if he dies of natural causes I had
nothing to do with that
Fair see Oliver tree said you were gonna
say [ __ ] like this dude he said you got
to really be careful around that guy
Oliver was right yeah he has monkey pox
so who's careful around him
Crowder said it's 100 gay
oh yeah that's true is that right no he
didn't he said why when are we gonna
start calling monkeypox a gay disease
and I just responded to it and I said
every single case
no obviously because
then we can't call it that can we
they're out in an absolute State disease
I mean that's like saying AIDS is a gay
disease well they did say that at first
and they hindered the [ __ ] yeah
also it's [ __ ] up because it makes
people think well I'm not gay I'm not
going to catch it and you do right
you're not careful seems bad by the way
you guys seen people suffering with the
monkey pox is it yeah I know nothing
about it excruciating pain really just
covered in like uh is it is it fit is it
fake no nobody's died of it in the US I
thought they I thought people I thought
it's like one percent kills one percent
of people I heard that stat but I also
heard that nobody in the United States
has died from it where we hear this Tick
Tock no I saw it on the news you think
we're heading towards I get all my news
off at Tick Tock so shut down I don't
because monkeypox is way less contagious
than oh really it's like not even the
same thing in my opinion because you
have to like literally touch a boil a
pus oh yeah like that's how you get it
like you have so people are getting it
from like bed sheets like at a hotel oh
my sitting on a toilet seat you know
software those people are gay that laid
on the bed sheets though is that right
got him yeah got him
but it's true most people catching it
are are you know gay but that's but but
yeah not all of them
and there you have it
all right well
that was not yeah no notes from us yeah
um thank you I think the only thanks
guys only one that needs to edit is you
all right we're done thank you everybody
for watching this is going up tomorrow
by the way yeah
all right shout out to the family yep
never go against the family garbage
all right